Oh r three listen,
you dirty freaks.
This is,
this is the commercial version of the podcast for commercial portion of the
podcast and sometimes when we do this thing we say funny shit and sometimes we
just get right to the point B.
You know why?
Because we're allowed to,
we can do whatever we want.
This is just a podcast.
There's,
there's no,
this is good things and bad things about that.
The bad things is,
yeah,
we fuck a lot of shit up,
but the good things is we don't have to listen to anybody else and the only
people that we work with are people that we actually like.
So if you hear a commercial from this podcast,
it's 100% because we are representing a cool company that has good ethics and
that sells a product that we think is legit and worth something.
One of them is kerosene games.
Kersey and Games is a company that we just started doing business with and
they're a startup.
This is their first game and they're making games directly for the IPAD and for
iPhones and starting,
I believe in February they're going to be available for high end android phones
as well.
So really cool game.
The first one is blade slinger and it's,
the graphics are fucking fantastic.
It's,
we're at a really cool time now and technology where the technology of just an
Ipad,
the visual processing power is just stunning and what they can do with these
things.
You know you used to take,
when I was gaming,
when I was really in a computer games,
what the hell was that when I was really into the game itself when I was a
really into computer games,
I had like a 400 megahertz PC with like some big giant stupid video card and
that couldn't do anything compared to the graphics power that these little iPads
have.
It's incredible.
They just can crunch images so well that you can have these beautiful games like
blade slayer and this game is made designed completely for the iPad and I touch
any touch.
It's touch screen device.
So they're not porting it over from a PC game.
It's a game they've designed to be intuitive with the controls that you can get
from touchscreen and the unprecedented visual quality.
I mean,
it's fucking beautiful and it's a really cool fun game.
It's filled with a lot of wacky nonsense.
You're like a cowboy in the future and you get the fuck shit up.
It's like a bionic cowboy.
What the fuck is a bionic cowboy is?
He really does.
You really have cows.
There's no cows in the student's life,
but whatever,
you're out there with this guy and you're fucking shit up.
And it's only $2 and 99 cents.
Um,
up until January 1st,
I think it was a dollar cause it yesterday,
whenever it was that it ended,
it's over bitch.
So now it's two 99,
but it's still a very good deal and a great company and they're,
they're cool to work with.
So we just started doing this with them.
Um,
so what if you're into video games,
uh,
support these people.
Go out and pick up the game.
It's 23 bucks.
You're going to miss three bucks and it's pretty dope.
And if you're on an airplane,
it will fucking save your mind.
Look at that thing.
The visual quality is just amazing.
We're also sponsored by Alpha brain,
uh,
on it.com we've talked about,
the,
uh,
the website on it so much that I,
I get sick when I have to spell it out when I have to double in it.
Uh,
but I have to,
because if you just go to onnit.com which is o nit,
it's like something totally different and you'll be fucking baffled.
But if you go to on it,
O n,
n I t you can use a code name Brogan and save 10% off any and all supplements,
all the Groovy Shit that we have to benefit your health and your mind.
And,
um,
this,
Whoa,
what are you doing?
You're dropping shit.
You don't even know what the fuck is going on over there.
There's a problem in the sound.
Do you hear that?
What does that technology technology just fucked this again?
Anyway,
um,
the,
uh,
the different products and everything we have at [inaudible] dot com is all shit
that we use or that we know is the best stuff available.
Like for instance,
we just started carrying Dave Asprey's coffee.
Um,
Dave Asprey.
I mean he like coffee.
Really coffee's good for you,
not nearly as bad for you as you think.
Here's the thing that according to Dave Asprey is bad for you.
Toxic mold.
And uh,
we had Bert Christ in the show yesterday.
He was on the travel channel with that,
uh,
that showed,
I think it's called dangerous grounds.
It's about the difficulty in acquiring like exotic coffees and all these
different places.
It's kind of traveling and a,
they were saying that it's just commonly known that mold is on like 90% of the
coffee that you buy.
And unfortunately a lot of that stuff is very bad for you.
We have Dave Asprey's would,
he calls upgraded coffee and this is a bulletproof executive guy.
That's a Dave Asprey's whole ideology is to be bulletproof,
have everything just rock solid,
have your health rock solid,
your mind rock solid.
I mean he's a bio hacker.
What does that mean?
You got to go to the bulletproof exec to understand it's all really intense shit
and I'm quite honestly a little bit too stupid to understand it,
but uh,
he's a brilliant guy and I had personally have benefited from a lot of the
things that I learned from the guy.
And uh,
so we just started carrying his coffee and that's the kind of shit we do.
Like if we,
you know,
kettle bells for instance,
I'm always preaching the,
the,
the use of kettle bells and functional strength and how it's so much better than
just going to a gym.
And it's like doing bench press and stuff like that.
Like you'd be amazed at how much a athletic benefit you can get from doing
functional strength exercises.
So we started carrying that.
We started carrying kettle bells and battle ropes and I'll any kind of different
shit that we think is going to benefit you physically and mentally.
I mean when we used to do music behind these,
that noise again though,
that crackly static things in the,
what's it say my headphones?
Can I interject a story on the way over casting every talking about mold and uh,
he,
we're talking about,
my wife grew up in Mozambique,
right?
And there are a lot of peanut based foods there and there's a mold that grows on
peanuts that really fucks up your liver.
So they're really high rates of liver cancer.
And she was saying she thinks that something that's underappreciated in the West
because there's so much peanut butter eating here and that's all industrial.
And there's of course there's mold growing on that,
you know,
but it goes into the peanut butter who notices?
Yeah.
I don't know what that survive the peanut butter making process.
Some of it would.
Yeah,
some like they say prions,
those things that create mad cow disease,
these can,
they can survive like a thousand degrees for like six hours or something crazy.
I mean you're talking about these weird super organisms that can stay alive and
to really disgusting situations.
You know,
mold.
That's crazy for human beings to be one of those organisms.
I mean,
do you ever been to like the bad part of Hong Kong?
Well,
I have a whole piece that I did in the opening of one of my comedy specials that
if you looked at the earth from outer space,
if you were an alien,
completely objective to our culture or our physical body,
right.
And you just looked at us,
you would say there,
this is a,
this is a mold.
This is like,
this is a growth round.
Yeah,
there's a big brown spreading things,
smokes coming out of them,
Burns everything up and shits it out.
And if you,
you know,
if the earth comes in and takes it back,
it's just rebuilt.
Just build back up.
But it's like a tumor that you can't get rid of.
Like it's a crazy idea when you,
but when you look at how much damage and devastation we really do to the world,
and it's not a bad analogy,
it's really,
if you,
if you are objective and you looked at it from outer space,
that you might look at it that way.
You make,
oh well this thing is infected with people.
You got to fucking people problem on this.
Pissing all is good too.
You got a people problem on this planet planet,
but it's fucking people there.
Ooh Man.
Do you know the earth almost wiped us out?
Yeah.
You mainly want to get on with your university
commercial.
Listen,
go to on it.
Get swole and press the fuck out of everybody.
Feel better about yourself.
Get your shit together and uh,
and use the code name,
Rogan and saved 10%
seen.
Also make it sponsor correction.
If we did set something wrong.
Yes,
yes,
definitely.
Okay.
I think yesterday you said that if you sign up for 10,
you get $50 credit,
but I think it's 25 now.
What will they changed it?
I,
if it was tin or it was one of the [inaudible] yesterday.
Well I just have to be,
it would have to be tank.
Hold on a second.
That's gross.
You can't do that.
Let me sent me a Twitter thing about Tang.
I did and I checked it out.
That's right.
Because you're a,
your cell phone.
You were talking to them about how bad your,
um,
your service was.
Yeah.
It looks good.
Tang.
It looks really good.
I liked what I saw.
Unfortunately,
I'm on an iPhone,
so
yeah,
they can't do that yet.
But I'm telling you,
man,
um,
if you,
if you fuck with these,
um,
these new Samsung Galaxy s three is,
it's the first film that I've ever used that not just rivals in iPhone,
but it,
yeah,
it's only $25 credit now.
Whoa.
It used to be 50 bucks.
Why didn't they let me know that?
Listen Tang you cheap cons,
that's only $25.
You just,
he just made us all look stupid for 25 bucks.
Do you really need that 25 bucks?
Well,
Joel,
it's $25 times.
How many people sign up and action?
My opinion,
it's very difficult when you give people money off and then you reduce that
shit,
especially if you don't tell,
you know,
like ladies and gentlemen,
I'm not telling you how to run your company.
Okay?
I use your phone.
You've got an excellent service.
I support it 100%.
But um,
you should have told me that it's 25 bucks.
Now you know what?
My dumb ass,
my dumb ass publisher two days ago sent out a new version to the kindle.
It erased everyone's notes that they'd taken on the first floor.
Oh No.
I get this review on amazon.com from this day and was like,
do not buy this fucking book.
They erased all my notes.
I had read 200 pages and no,
uh oh no.
Nice move.
Harpercollins well,
unbeknownst to them,
yeah,
we have a podcast to run,
but we need to play music before it's official.
That's fucked up though.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Yes.
Uh,
Chris Ryan,
how are you sir?
Thanks for doing this man.
I really appreciate it.
I'm sorry if we allegedly got you too high before the show to talk.
Well,
that long commercial gave me a chance to calm down.
That's what those are good for.
You stumbled through those commercials.
It's sorta like,
it's Sorta like when you,
uh,
have a car and it's a manual and it,
it can't start button.
You could push that pitch and then pop the tab.
I'll start and then once it's gone,
you're okay.
Right.
That's what it's like.
So the commercial access,
so sort of like a scaffolding for us to get our,
or our sea legs under us for,
we,
uh,
venture out into the podcast world.
Right.
So,
uh,
thanks for doing this man.
Your book,
if people don't know it's called sex at dawn.
And uh,
it was suggested to me by our very good friend Duncan Trussell and a,
I read it and I fucking loved it,
man.
It's a really,
really interesting stuff,
you know?
Uh,
I,
I use the,
uh,
the one,
one of the things that I read that was,
that never heard before.
It was the origins of the word [inaudible].
Yeah.
That's really fascinating stuff,
man.
Yeah,
it was a misunderstanding.
And that what the,
is it out Mayan person mean?
Who would you say,
where am I in mind?
Yeah.
That what they were saying was essentially,
I don't understand.
You ask him,
what does this place called?
Right?
They were saying,
I don't understand you and that I don't understand.
You became right in a garbled sort of a way,
what they described the areas exactly describing it as I don't understand.
Yeah.
It's amazing because it sounds so authentic.
If you say,
well,
we went camping in the Yucatan,
it's like,
you know,
you sound like,
you're like fucking eating organic salads and doing the right thing.
You're out in nature.
But meanwhile what you're,
you're,
you're at.
I don't know,
understand you.
That's where you are.
That's,
that's,
that is,
uh,
in my opinion,
like if you look at the whole human race,
that's a good example of like how,
how screw Bali,
this whole system that we operate under is for it.
You know?
It's like,
Whoa,
like that's still the name.
Like it's still America.
How about that?
How about there's still Indians?
You know what,
how about,
that's even more ridiculous when we name ourselves after some dude that nobody
knows.
You ask any kid who Mary and Mary Gove was Poochie.
Is that what his name was?
The Guy Who American?
Yeah.
Maybe like the only Italian who ever did anything in those days,
you know,
other than write poems and check.
But I mean,
as far as exploring,
you don't hear a lot about the Italian explorer and we still celebrate Columbus
Day,
although it's incredibly clear now.
The Columbus was a huge asshole.
Do you know about Columbus?
I talking about like original encounters,
right?
When Columbus,
uh,
first arrived in Hispaniola on the first trip,
he was,
he wrote a letter back to the queen explaining what this place was like that he,
he and his men had found.
Right.
And it's amazing to read because the first nine sentences are all about how
great the people are,
how they,
they,
um,
you know,
if there's food,
they share it without thinking.
If,
if you admire a piece of clothing,
they give it to you without thinking.
They're incredibly generous.
They're incredibly healthy,
beautiful,
nicely foreign bodies.
They've got fruit in the trees and all the fish they could possibly want.
He said with 500 men,
I could subjugate the entire island.
Wow.
Or however many,
200 or whatever it was.
But it's just this whole litany of how wonderful these people are.
In fact,
it's even thought by some historians that the reason that people are called
Indians is not this whole thing about Columbus thinking he was going to India.
Right.
It's actually that in this document that I'm describing to you,
Columbus wrote [inaudible] even Indios,
which means these are certain,
certainly people who live in God.
Whoa.
Indios and in Spanish they're still calling Dios,
right?
Yeah.
Wow.
Crazy.
Huh?
Wow.
I mean,
we came so close.
He could have just said,
fuck Europe.
Let's stay here.
Right.
Which other people did other explorers did do.
It's very difficult when someone's a client to turn them around and it's very
difficult when that's the culturally accepted way to live.
What does that noise,
man,
do you have your plan Schamens Shit in the background,
dude.
I thought it was crazy.
Crickets.
Did you even know you were doing that?
That wasn't the purpose was it?
It turned on by itself,
I think.
Uh,
like it's on a,
it was playing the,
nevermind.
It's stupid stuff.
You got bugs getting computers.
Literally.
Yeah.
That sounded like there was some dude in the background with like a rattle.
It would be dancing in some way.
Maybe trying to bring back the old days.
It was the Joe Rogan theme on repeat in the background turned down Super Low.
The Owl,
I mean it would be so difficult when you grow up in uh,
the environment of the 14 hundreds and Europe,
which was just chaos and disease and war and famine and you know,
all these goddamn problems.
And then to like a band in that once you got here,
I think they probably couldn't do it.
I think there were just so fucked.
And then
all of the also like Desperado from a couple of months in a boat on the ocean,
you know,
that's got to drive you fucking squirrely your,
your,
your feelings about human life have to erode.
I mean they have to,
your appreciation for human life has to erode.
And it's like really worst case scenario,
you take the craziest Fox,
you can find people that are willing to get on a fro,
a floating piece of wood and you're gonna push it out into this never ending
ocean.
And it might take a few months and some of you are going to die.
Who's in?
Who's that in it's self selection mechanism at work there.
You ever seen the Hertzog film a good are any of the wrath of God?
No,
but oh,
you got to see that.
What is that about?
It's about the conquistadores in Brazil and it's the main lead.
The lead role is played by Klaus Kinski who is this super intense too?
I'm actually,
Mick Jagger was suppose supposed to play the role,
but he,
he got sick or he had a concert or there was some delay.
He couldn't do it.
So they running Kinski how many movies is ain't Jagger done?
I know.
It's a weird choice.
Yeah.
No,
Mick Jagger was the first choice.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Wow.
I love that shit.
I love,
I mean that,
that's a great movie.
But what was the other one?
Uh,
do you know who was supposed to play Hannibal Lecter?
Who?
It was first offered the role and turned it down.
Keith Richards.
Jack Nicholson.
Whoa.
Imagine that role with Jack Nicholson or it would have been different.
It would've been great,
but very different.
Yeah.
It probably would have been equally great just to sit in a different way,
you know?
And you know,
people would go crazy.
No.
It must be Anthony Hopkins,
like relax.
No,
it must not be.
You know,
when Nicholson first came to Hollywood,
he was a screenwriter.
He wasn't an actor.
Really.
Yeah.
And he was,
uh,
he was living with this dude who was an act or trying to be an actor.
They're sharing a room somewhere,
a place somewhere.
And I,
the story as it was told to me was that Nicholson was so unsuccessful selling
stuff that he was ready to go back to Kansas or wherever the fuck he was from
our new,
yeah.
Kansas,
I think.
And his friends had just come to this audition with me,
man.
Maybe you'll get an extra roll or something.
Just some money.
So he,
he read for the role and the producers said,
Mr. Nicholson,
we don't need you for this,
but if we ever need,
you will need you very much.
Hmm.
You think about that in terms of Nicholson?
He's always Nichols.
You know,
he's always jack.
He can't be anything other than Jack.
Yeah.
There's an issue with guys that get to a certain role,
like,
uh,
like sort of like a characteristic role.
Like Al Pachino like your voice has to yell now he's in like,
he's always got to have begged,
beg,
preferably blind screaming.
You know,
like when he played the devil,
that dude jump the shark and everybody played the devil.
Was it a Keanu Reeves movie?
Didn't even remember the advocate.
Is that what it was?
Yeah,
he played the devil.
I'm like,
listen,
the devil would not be so fucking verbose.
Devil wouldn't be screaming.
Why?
Devil wouldn't even be emotional with sand.
You don't understand what real torture would be like.
Would it be some little fucking old dude screaming,
stop it.
Terracing yourself.
Reptilian evil's got to be reptilian.
Sure.
Obviously planned out rant.
You stop it.
Devil scare me.
You got the devil.
That's the devil lying to you.
Trying to trick you into thinking that he's not that.
Not that scary.
There wasn't that.
That was Terence Mckenna.
His idea of what,
um,
what aliens really where is that aliens would,
uh,
hide themselves in the,
the idea of an extraterrestrial being,
uh,
that looked like us and walked like this and flew in space ship.
They would hide themselves in that form as to not disturb us with their true
identity,
which would it be?
So alien should be incomprehensible.
So that,
you know,
he thought that that's what they were doing when they were appearing in such
weird sort of a classic forum.
You're talking about the little Elvin things,
a little grays with the big black flash around.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is it,
this is something that they would,
they would hide in.
Terence mechanic got me in a lot of trouble.
How's that?
I was,
uh,
well this is the last time I took acid.
Um,
I got some acid from a guy who sort of knew the grateful dead and so the acid
was coming from this pure source,
pretty sweet source from the stream.
So I s I said,
yeah,
I'll take some fine.
Um,
and this guy gave me all this liquid,
right?
And I gave something to some friends and whatever cause I,
what am I going to do with a hundred hits of acid?
You know,
I was like shirty five or something.
And uh,
so one friend of mine is a psychiatrist and he's like 50 or something.
This is in Spain.
And he had,
he had done acid back when psychiatrists would order it and you know,
from Santos and they just send it mail order.
And so he tried three hits and came back the next day and said,
yeah,
that's good.
It's clean,
it's mellow,
it's cool.
So I was reading Terence Mckenna and all this shit about heroic doses.
Right.
And I had like done a bunch of acid when I was younger,
but I never like it had been awhile since I'd approached anything.
You could call it heroic dose.
And so I thought this is the last time I'm probably going to trip,
right?
I,
I'm sort of at the end of this part of my life,
I think.
So I'm going to go out with a bang and I took four hits of this stuff and it
turned into a very intense afternoon that ended up with me.
Uh,
a few steps from a psychiatric hospital.
Yeah.
I think it was Howard Howard
stern who had a story about taking acid in like losing his mind for like a
couple of weeks.
They took too much.
You can,
you can get to a point on a psychedelic trip where
you question reality to the t,
like to the brink of sanity.
You know,
you get like,
you don't,
you don't know if you're ever going to get back from this one.
Yeah.
I mean honestly that's not a feeling that I've had much tripping and that's why
I love tripping because I always felt I really had my feet under me and you
know,
if I was with people and Shit went down,
which at sometimes did,
um,
I was like the go to guy,
you can keep it together,
right?
Like I could always like,
okay,
get down to,
it's just funnier.
We'd like to be cocky and think that we can handle it because we've handled it
before.
Right.
But then all you have to do is just to keep going with the level,
right.
I'll take five minutes.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
Can you handle Phi and then you're a baby once again.
Well,
the thing is recognizing where your limits are and approaching them,
testing them,
but not ever crossing number.
Disrespecting them.
And that's the way you ride a motorcycle.
It's,
I like to do dangerous things in a smart way so I don't die.
But I like doing interesting,
exciting,
crazy things.
You know,
the problem with acid or any of the drugs that are not legal is that we don't
necessarily know what we're getting.
You know,
if you go to a vodka store,
so liquor store rather than,
you buy vodka pretty pretty well be assured that you're buying vodka,
right?
I mean,
it's a pretty standard.
Everyone knows that the dosage have a couple of shots,
you're gonna get fucked up.
That's cultural sort of information that's passed on and it's super readily
available.
Whereas with drugs,
there's a lot of,
are you sure?
Are you sure he's done this?
Where'd this come from?
Who got this?
If you're smart,
you're doing that.
If you're not,
you take some pills somebody gives you.
And I used to do a lot of research.
I didn't do research.
I wrote about research that was happening in the world of psychedelics.
Right?
And people saw,
I gave talks at medical schools and you know,
I'd go around and sort of be the authority figure on this.
And so people always came up to me afterwards like,
Hey,
you know,
what's the deal with ecstasy?
Really?
Is it dangerous?
Is it not dangerous?
And it's always complicated because it's exactly what you're saying.
If your MDM is one thing,
but what you're buying in a club is if you're lucky,
partly Mtma,
it might not have any MDM at all,
or at least it's a minor ingredient and there's a bunch of other shit in there
that's unregulated and controller,
nobody knows what it is.
In Spain you can send to ecstasy to allow or their guys in the clubs with labs
that will test it for you.
Yeah,
I just got it.
I got some tested the other day that smoked.
I guess that was the big thing of it's smoke.
That means it's like almost a hundred percent pure and it was night and day
difference from what I was used to taking.
It was just like fall to the ground and melt.
It was amazing.
Right,
right.
It's a very different thing and like you say,
it's dangerous,
you know,
because the shit that they mix in them,
but acid,
LSD isn't really like that too much because it's very cheap and easy to make LSD
relatively for a chemist.
So whole new fad lst
occasionally like what's mad?
The whole thing in the 60 like don't eat the brown acid was government
propaganda and mass hysteria because Lsd as I,
I'm no chemist,
but I've been told LSD is like if you set up a lab to make LSD to just make LSD
but you're not,
there's nothing that's going to be cheaper or easier to make instead.
Whereas Mtma is much more complicated.
And then there's money in mixing shit in MDME.
Lsd seems to me to be a legitimate threat to your sanity.
There's,
there's a,
there's quite a few people that have gone bonkers after big LSD hits.
It seems to me that if you don't have a good solid grip on it,
there's a,
it's possible for it to get away from you and you never get it back.
Yeah.
They suspected that happened to the unibomber.
Ted Kaczynski was a part of the,
uh,
the Harvard,
a psychedelic studies like the,
in the no real SD studies.
And,
uh,
when he got out of school,
he,
uh,
he went and taught for a few years to save up all his money so he could get this
cabin and then start his attack on,
on technology.
But,
you know,
the thought was that they cooked his brain.
There was a documentary detailing,
I think it's called the net thing.
That's a foreign documentary and it's in subtitles.
But look that up again.
But,
but do you really think Kaczynski was insane?
Oh,
well,
obviously it was insane.
He thinks killing all these fucking people.
Yeah.
But wasn't he operating essentially out of the same thing that you and I were
talking about earlier where we said you got a people problem on that planet.
Yeah.
He was sort of like sort of murdering innovators.
That's not the way that,
that's insanity.
It's 100% Saturday.
You know,
even if you thought that the world was doing something bad,
that there was something wrong with,
how wouldn't you work to try to change it?
Why would you work to try to kill the people that are creating technology?
I can't,
I mean that's the thing.
If you think technology's the enemy,
I'm not,
I'm,
I'm not an advocate for the uniform.
I think that that's a limited way of looking at things.
Cause I think the technology,
uh,
the,
the way human beings operate as the technology will always constantly move,
be moving forward.
We're always going to try to innovate.
Where are we going to try to create better and new things.
But I think that same sort of mentality can be applied to cleaning things up or
using things in a sustainable way.
And I don't think that it's outside the realm of possibility for us to figure
out a way to process pollution and make it turn into some sort of a clean fuel.
I think the idea of making hydrogen and are using hydrogen and hydrogen turns
into water,
you know,
which is,
there's,
there's ways we can have fuel and energy that in the future that we can't figure
it out right now,
but there's,
there's potential in the future for cleaning up the environment,
cleaning up the air,
and actually using that as fuel.
You know,
it is possible.
I read somewhere I just,
in the last few days like Norway or Denmark,
one of those countries is importing garbage from other countries to use as a
fuel source because they don't have enough of their own garbage.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
There is so fucking smart in those little small European countries like Iceland,
Lee,
through all the bankers in jail,
they only have to be fucking assholes and elected a lesbian to president.
Powerful lesbian trailer,
by the way.
Oh,
is this it?
No,
this is not,
that is not this.
Brian,
stop it.
Sandra Bullock.
No,
no,
no.
It was a documentary.
You fuck
you guys being silly over there and then on purpose.
Did you do that on purpose?
It's not the end.
All right,
so talking about the evils of technology,
right?
Yeah.
That day I took all that acid,
I went into this park with his friend and we were lying under a tree and my
friend was like,
not,
I got to walk,
I gotta to move.
And he's like,
okay,
you move man.
I'm just going to stay under this tree.
I'm under this tree and it's this big beautiful tree.
Don't over.
And it's uh,
you know,
you can see the blue sky behind the leaves twittering and stuff.
It's just so nice.
And I started getting into the vibe of this tree and I could actually like feel
the vibrations of the tree,
the,
the energy vibrations of this tree.
And,
and I would align my own energetic vibrations with the,
those of the tree.
And it was like a fucking brain orgasm.
It would just be like,
and like,
whoa.
And I couldn't take more than a few seconds of it.
So then I'd like get out of phase,
right.
And then just sorta like,
oh,
this is all like with my conscious energies.
It's sort of dancing around,
getting into and out of phase with this tree's energy and every time it was like
a full brain orgasm.
It was amazing.
Wow.
So anyway,
I'd have to like an hour or two of this.
I was exhausted.
I walked out and I sent it to try to walk.
I got out and walked out from under the tree and I still heard this buzzing the
vibrations of the tree.
We're sort of moving with me.
I turned,
I look back and right above the tree where these high tension power lines and
the buzz was coming from the electrical cables on the power of God.
I thought I was making love with nature.
I was being fucked by technology.
I felt so violated.
What do you think was going on then when you were trying to tune into the energy
of the train?
It had all this electricity,
like what was going on?
Some sort of,
you know,
energy overload,
frying the circuits.
In my brain.
They say when you're around certain certain of those towers,
you could feel it like you feel like it just feels fucked up.
It feels like there's,
we used to,
when I was a kid,
we used to take 'em fluorescent light bulbs out and if you walked under them
with the light bulbs at night,
they'd light up,
get the fuck out of here.
They light up
with that made the people that lived under,
I'm like,
have superpowers.
Could you imagine everybody wouldn't want to live underneath that and take the
chances if like one dude became the flash,
like from like DC comic book,
She's like,
you grow up,
you're a baby under electricity.
Constantly.
Just,
you just see things that other people can't see,
but no,
actually it fucks her.
Right.
Yeah.
It's not good to live into those things and I don't think so.
I think it's a,
if they ever shown that health wise to be,
if they did,
I doubt there'd be houses underneath them still,
but I don't think there are houses underneath them.
I'm good at Burbank.
It's fucking crazy.
Oh yeah.
Out in the country.
They cut a line through the woods for them.
They don't build houses in Durham.
Yeah.
Those things are creepy as fuck.
It seems like a stupid way to do it.
You know,
in Europe.
Cables or awards.
I mean those are above ground,
but most cables in Europe or underground.
Yeah.
Why aren't these underground?
Why didn't they have them on the ground?
Well,
actually they would worry about some of digging in there and hit me.
Um,
have you ever seen what happens when they fuck up and hit like a gas line and
blow up a whole block?
You know,
I,
have you ever seen those?
They,
one of them have on recently,
I believe it was Indiana.
It was unbelievable.
The destruction.
They,
someone tapped into a gas line in the house was just devastated.
It,
whatever happened,
it was probably the pilot light in the,
uh,
the stove or something,
you know,
some sort of a gas leak.
There was no house.
It was nothing.
And in the houses next to it,
we're all fucked up too.
But it was just complete splinters.
And these are like in our neighborhood.
It's like there's bombs everywhere.
Just waiting to go off like high pressure gas being pumped into almost
everyone's house.
He sounded like woody Allen and everybody's cool with it.
Woody Allen.
Woody Allen talking like that.
A fearful bombs everywhere waiting to go off that.
He's a,
I mean if you're near a house that did that,
what you would start thinking that it's just a weed or a house that did that.
You wouldn't be thinking at all,
man,
what of your fairly close within a couple of blocks and do managers survive?
But then you stop and think about it and go,
what the fuck man.
See,
pull up some photos,
man.
The Indiana a house explosion ago.
Yeah,
the,
that's nothing though.
That's,
there's still a house.
It's on fire and everything,
but it's still a house in Indiana.
Like the house was gone.
There was no house,
you know,
these are like tornado or something.
We were just so willy nilly with the fact that we've got gigantic sources of
power and our grasp all the time,
electricity and every wall in your house.
And very few people even understand it.
We just so turn the light switch on,
turn the light,
switch off,
no thinking.
Meanwhile,
some poor fuck has to put up those crazy cables
and hope that it doesn't give him cancer too.
So,
um,
this book that you wrote is a,
I would have to say a very controversial book.
Was it you or was it Bert Kreischer that was telling us a story about,
uh,
someone was at Bert about bringing up sex at dawn and someone got angry.
Oh No,
I bought it a long time ago in a Dunkin first started talking about it.
He just got it.
I think he told me that he's like,
you should check out this book man.
And I was like,
okay.
So that's how I bought it.
And then,
uh,
I started reading it and then I left it in my car.
And then the girl I was dating at the time was like,
what's this book I want a book to read tonight?
I'm like,
all right.
I take that.
And I'm like,
then right when I'm giving it to her,
I'm like,
wait,
that was probably a really bad idea what I heard.
You know why?
Because she read it and she was just like,
oh my God,
this is so anti marriage and blah blah blah and anti relationship and,
and stuff like that.
And she didn't like whatever.
She read to me what you're saying.
She didn't know.
She just got upset.
She's like,
why are you reading this book?
Like she almost got nervous,
you know?
That's hilarious.
You know what I uh,
first really one of the first people that read the book was,
I guess I can say his name.
What the fuck?
What was his name?
He was a child actor.
He was in,
in YPD blue.
Ricky Schroeder.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
We know Ricky.
What did he say?
Oh fuck,
I shouldn't tell you this story.
He's crazy.
He's a nice guy.
But go ahead and tell the story story is that,
uh,
okay.
So I met him right at lax.
I didn't know who he was.
We started talking,
we're on the same flight to Spain,
actually London and then Barcelona.
Right.
Cause he was living in Barcelona for a while and it asked me what I did.
I said,
I just about to publish this book.
I had one in the galleys,
the early,
the prepublication copies and we talked about the book and then he came back,
he was in first class or something.
He came back,
there were empty seats and he and I sat and talked like most of the way to
London and he was really excited about it.
He was like,
this is going to be amazing.
This is really interesting,
you know?
And,
and then we talked about a screenplay,
his cause he was like,
you know,
could you do,
is there a movie in this?
And he told me about a movie he was working on at the time about Arab terrorists
or something like that.
Anyway.
Um,
so,
uh,
he was really into it and I told him the screenplay idea and he was like,
yeah,
Kevin Kline in the lead and you know,
we're talking about who would look and he was like super enthusiastic.
So he said,
do you have a kid?
I read the book and you have a car.
I said,
I've got this like one copy,
it's my last copy,
but it'll be out in two months,
you know,
whatever.
But yeah,
you can have this great cause I'm going skiing in France or Switzerland or
somewhere and I'll read it.
And uh,
so he was going to get in touch with me when he's back in Barcelona a couple of
weeks,
never heard from the guy.
And so it's talking to Stanley,
my professor about this.
And Stanley said,
well,
you know,
I'm going to see Ricky Schroder and two months in Washington at this event for
veterans,
I'll ask him what,
what's up?
So he did,
he saw a Ricky at this thing and he said,
hey,
you met this friend of mine and you know,
you were really interested in all this stuff.
What happened?
And Ricky's wife,
according to Stanley,
said I threw that book in the trash.
Nobody talks to Ricky about sex except me.
Whoa.
Yeah,
that's the story I heard.
Well the,
I would never repeat that story because it's a store that you heard.
It's really hard to get a real solid story through more than one person.
So it was just one person.
But even I,
I,
I mean if we could cut it out,
cut it out as live.
Oh really?
It's live.
It's all of this is live.
Um,
I,
well,
you know,
who knows,
who knows what.
Anyways,
ocean,
they had wine is that a lot girlfriends and wives have been a non interested in
the book and also husbands.
I got to say,
Ricky's a very nice guy.
Um,
he's a,
he's a friend of the family.
Told him I said Hi.
I've hung out with him and his wife many times.
What was his wife's a wonderful lady.
Oh no thank you.
Said tell him he could cut it out.
Good.
I didn't know.
I don't know.
Knows what really happened.
Listen man,
people get into situations.
It's not bad.
You know,
it's your,
your book to a lot of people that have sort of a Sandra Bullock movie view of
the world.
It becomes very disconcerting.
The idea of for folks who don't know,
uh,
sex at dawn.
Oh,
how would you describe the book and what's the,
the best description of it?
Looking at,
uh,
the origin and evolution of human sexuality.
So it's,
it's sort of looking at how human beings behave sexually.
Before there were
civilizations telling them what to do and what not to do.
Now when that subject gets breached,
for whatever reason,
a lot of women will panic.
Like if you start talking about what people used to do orgiastic culture and for
whatever reason,
like the,
the idea that somehow or another things were different at one point in time and
you know,
maybe males would find that more preferable or maybe you know,
whatever it is that freaks them out when a guy would read a book like that,
that's sort of describing just basically a statement of pretty much fact of
history.
There's a tremendous amount of evidence to backup the idea that there were
orgiastic cultures.
So what's wrong with saying that?
Like I don't,
that that becomes like a real weird,
do you,
did you feel a lot of that?
Did you feel that your people,
sure.
Sure.
You know,
and there's a good reason for that response.
I mean,
the fact is that women are in a situation now and have been for millennia where
the only thing they're,
the only way they could survive really was through a man,
either their father or their husband
and,
and the only thing they had to negotiate with was their sexuality because the
men can,
men had all the property,
all the money,
all the power,
all the,
everything.
The only thing women had was their sexuality.
So it's not surprising that women feel threatened if the value of that
negotiating chip is lessened as it is.
If you start talking about orgiastic societies,
right,
then you don't trade your sexuality for your food,
your status and all that other stuff.
Um,
but the key is to understand that they didn't need to,
our ancestors did need to because the women had direct access to their food and
their status and whatever they needed.
In terms of power.
These are very egalitarian societies,
but we're not in an egalitarian society.
Now.
It's getting better,
although women are still making 70 cents on the dollar to men for the same work.
Um,
but yeah,
if you're a single mother,
it's tough in this,
in this specialty in the United States because you're not getting much support.
So those women feel threatened if their negotiating position visa vi man is,
is threatened,
uh,
as it is.
If you start talking about loosening up sexual morality,
that's funny.
Then negotiating position,
that's really funny.
That's,
and that essentially is what a lot of men become.
They become negotiating positions.
It's a very disturbing thing to see your friends sort of co opted by some chick
who sort of made her way into his life and now as a inside of him like a
parasite working the controls,
it becomes really weird.
Becomes really weird to say.
Yeah.
But it's also,
I mean,
we should never forget that women are put in that position.
They don't necessarily choose,
it's not their nature.
In other words,
the gold,
you know,
we're talking about gold diggers or whenever we're talking about,
it prostitutes,
whatever,
women who are trading their sexuality for something explicitly,
but we put them in that position.
How is that so if some women don't do it?
Well,
they,
I mean,
women do it to the sentence,
you know,
like the,
uh,
I think it's all just a matter of circumstance and a matter of where they are,
they are and how it turns out because there's a lot of women who obviously don't
do any of those things because they can work for the first time in western
history.
So we have to understand that it's a very novel moment in our history.
And you still go to play,
you know,
Pakistan or you know,
most of Africa,
most of Latin America,
women don't have direct access to what they need.
So in the origins of civilization,
like when we moved from having the sort of a small tribes,
people to larger cities,
is that when the transition sort of happened for women and women became reliant
upon men and their jobs less than,
because now they're living in cities and well before cities even just just
settled,
um,
society.
So we're talking about the advent of agriculture,
which is about 10,000 years ago at the earliest.
And what's important to understand there is that that's when the notion of
private property really entered human society according to our vision of,
of this stuff.
Um,
so women weren't th that that affected women in two ways.
One way is that it became very important to trace property.
So you had to know who your sons were because it was going,
it was my,
uh,
patrilineal,
right?
So it's going down.
The mail.
Property was passed father to son.
So who are your sons?
Well,
the only way to know they're your sons is controlling this woman's sexuality,
right?
That's the only way.
And there are no DNA tests.
Right?
And also this is the time when people started breeding animals.
So it became very clear that one sex act could result in a offspring.
Um,
so,
so this is very important thing.
And if you look in the Bible,
uh,
what's the line?
Thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife.
Right?
That sounds like something that's talking about respecting your neighbors
marriage.
But if you read it in context that continues nor his house,
nor his servants,
nor his ox or his sheep,
et cetera.
So it's now shalt not covet thy neighbor's property and his wife is just part of
the property.
So women really became like,
they went from having nearly equal status to males and almost every hunter
gatherer society that we know of to being property.
That's fascinating.
What prompted that?
I mean,
what,
how did that,
uh,
how did they morph from these tribal societies of equality to these,
you know,
city societies?
Well,
it's obviously it would be very complicated to talk about all the different
things that happen,
but it's important to understand that the life human life before,
um,
civilization or the agriculture and after agriculture changed radically in
almost every way our diet,
our exercise patterns,
our understanding of interpersonal relationships,
governmental structure,
how we're,
how we rule,
what kind of decision making happens.
Childcare,
sexuality,
yeah,
it's really fucked up everything about it,
but a society,
a city,
uh,
you know,
agriculture,
that was really the first technology.
It's like you don't think of it as technology,
but that really was when they figured out how to create things and build things
and set things up that made life more convenient for them or made life easier.
And then from then it's really been all about accelerating that process,
accelerating that process of invention and innovation,
which really started off with agriculture.
If you really stop and think about what we were like when we were hunters and
gatherers,
these small tribes,
a very tightly knit people that had to stay together and lived off the land to
the first city.
From that point on,
it was a one way ticket to nuclear explosions.
It was just,
we were just on our way to innovating and creating more shelter and safety so
you can create better and crazier shit.
I mean literally the first house,
the first,
the first city,
the first fence is they set up.
That was a,
that was the,
the first steps.
And if you follow it to the pollution of the earth and the nuclear explosions
and the space shuttle,
all the different things that we've done,
that it literally all comes from that idea.
If we never did that,
we would be living exactly like these people that are living in tribal
situations in the Amazon and parts of Africa.
It's,
it's kind of amazing.
Yeah.
And they'll see that at the beginning of,
of that you said to make life easier
or whatever.
I shouldn't say easier.
Make it easier.
Right then
it is.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's easier right then.
But yeah,
that's the key.
And people often say,
well then why,
you know,
why did we choose to do this if,
cause we argue pretty strongly in sex at dawn and,
and then the next book is called civilized to death.
And I told you where I'm going with that one.
Right?
Um,
so I really question whether it's made life easier or better,
you know,
and so that's the argument I want to make in that book.
Um,
but you know,
people think of it as if we chose it as if our ancestors chose like,
hey,
let's all just hang out here and plant some corn,
you know,
whatever.
No,
what,
what seems to have happened,
agriculture is arisen four or five different times.
Bontanica something different parts of the world.
And in all of those different parts of the world in the years before by looking
at pollen,
a residue and fossils and stuff,
they can tell that the years before the advent of agriculture generally attended
to be a unusually rich,
lots of rain,
fall,
lots of plant life,
lots of life going on.
And then,
um,
and then they entered a period where it tightened up and there's much less
rainfall.
And that's when I grew culture arose.
So you see that pattern all around.
So the I,
the thinking is,
okay,
you've got really rich environment 20,
30,
40 years,
right?
Several generations,
population levels get really high.
Then suddenly there's a contraction.
So suddenly there's not enough food for everybody,
right?
Because hunter gatherer societies tended to be pretty much in balance with like
every other species with the food supply.
So suddenly there's way overpopulation,
most of the time they would just die off.
But occasion,
you know,
in these five instances,
someone figured out like,
wait a minute,
this is where all these things grow.
There's not enough water,
but there's a stream over there.
We could dig a channel.
So generally the first steps of agriculture,
I thought to have been the irrigation.
Then later they figured out,
wait,
we could take the seeds and put the seeds over here.
First it was just bringing the water to where the staff was.
And it's the,
it's really freaky when they,
uh,
they keep moving the date of that actually happening back further and further
and further.
They've just found evidence of cheesemaking from one to 7,000 years.
Yeah.
They found evidence in the area near go Beckley Tempe where they might've been
making beer 10,000 years ago.
It's a really fascinating,
like if they keep going further and further back to when people actually figured
it out,
but,
and apparently hemp was the first thing ever cultivated.
Pretty crazy.
So easy to do.
Stoners figured it out,
you know?
Uh,
the not hydroponic.
They were in soil.
Yeah.
They didn't figure out the whole closet setup yet.
We'd go over someone's house and you're like,
why are you fucking,
why did it so the hum,
what does that home,
what's that light coming out from under the door and that door?
And you go,
whoa.
Yeah,
that the feeling that you,
you,
uh,
didn't really get,
but thought you got it from a tree.
Like you can Kinda,
you can get a weird communication when you're in a room full of weed plants.
I love,
I love growing marijuana.
Really in Spain it's legal man,
and I had plans
every summer on our terrorists that were like Christmas trees by the end of the
summer.
It's so stupid that people think that if you want to,
if you want pot to be legal,
than you also probably want to overthrow the government and you know what I
mean?
I don't support taxes and you'd think we should be all hippies.
No,
no,
stupid.
You shouldn't be able to tell people what they can and can't do.
Right.
When it's been clearly proven to not be nearly as dangerous as almost everything
else on the world.
Right.
It's just so stupid.
It's so stupid at this point in time that you can't have a house,
a room in your house.
We just have all these plants hanging out and you can go in there and chill with
them.
Know,
well,
our cats always would hang out in the plant.
Halian fuckers cancer,
a little fucking Weirdos.
If you could just teach them to hunt those little worms,
you know,
like make yourself useful,
Pete.
The worms.
The first time I ever went to a grow room can now granted I was intoxicated.
I was under the spell of the sacred plant,
but when I walked into that room,
it was literally like walking into like a,
like a different sort of consciousness.
There was like a different sort of a life coming out of these plants and there's
like 20 or 30 of them in this room and they were huge.
And I remember being in there going,
whoa,
like this feels crazy.
Like this feels like these things are,
they're aware or if not aware there's something coming off of them.
It's not as simple as a,
you know,
this is a rock.
This statistic,
I wasn't that stone.
I was stolen but not like stoned enough through.
I thought that,
uh,
you know,
I wasn't really here anymore.
It wasn't that,
it was just fairly normal.
It was like I am right now.
But just walking into the room was like,
Whoa,
like this is a,
this is intense.
I wonder what that is.
And then people will tell you that like you can talk around plants and it
actually makes them grow better.
But how much of that is horse shit you ever been to Findhorn no.
You know what I'm talking about that that's where the whole playing music for
your plants and talk to them and they'll vet,
uh,
started in northern Finland.
I heard,
sorry.
Scotland's the music part is bullshit,
but the talking part or there's some evidence that shows that it might actually
help.
Yeah.
I haven't investigated it myself,
but well,
I know that if I went over to your house and all your plants are wilted,
I might think you're creepy.
Fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
If you go over someone's house and they're fucking plants are all jack like
toxic.
I kill Pam is Joe at my house.
I'm like those bamboo,
good luck bamboo plants there almost should not be able to kill him things and
you just put it in bottled water and I still kept those things somehow.
Oh Man,
I'm glad you're proud.
I'm not proud,
excited.
They just dial in life forms.
I put him cat cats are weird animals.
I've been,
they,
you know,
they would make sense that they would go and hang out in the weed room,
you know?
Sure.
To pick up on it.
Smells good.
Yeah.
And plus it looks like the jungle,
those little creepy fucks.
All those trees are probably thinking that there'll be a little jack something.
It's
funny,
we have a cat,
a cat.
I love cats.
I have two cats.
They're,
you know,
they're selfish little assholes.
But um,
it's weird.
My cat is it just a big fluffy cat?
She's 16 years old,
but I put her in the yard and there was a bird in the yard and she fucking went
after it and try to kill it.
I mean,
it's like you can have him in the house given I'm Kat from him for 16 years,
but he'd get them anywhere near a bourbon.
They go fucking crazy.
They will eyes go and then they make that noise.
Is your cat have one of those cat water fountains?
I just got one.
It's the coolest thing.
Cats love the waterfowl moving water.
So cool.
So they play with it as I wanted to just sit there and put their mouth in it and
just sit there.
And then my cat just like wipes his face and then wipes.
It's Paul's in it.
I was playing with it.
Tell,
give me a link and I'll uh,
powerful Amazon.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
you know about toxoplasma.
Do you know about all that?
Oh yeah.
The strange little thing that makes mice attracted to the smell of cat piss.
Yeah.
What a great evolutionary quirk that had.
It removes their fear of them too strange.
Yeah.
And uh,
the,
the crazy thing is the numbers of humans in the,
in the planet that are infested with this stuff.
Yeah.
That it affects behavior.
And that might be,
they said to France at one point in time was higher than 60%.
Yeah.
They say they've got it down to around 50 something now,
but I mean,
how the fuck do they know who's getting tested for toxo plasma they think is at
least 60 million Americans that haven't,
I think it's related to schizophrenia or they said could be,
they don't know.
They know that there's a sub,
Paul ski out of Stanford is a,
the leading guy in it.
I've been trying to get him.
Yeah,
he's a primatologist.
He's a really interesting guy.
He's a fascinating dude.
He apparently is uh,
the,
the leading light in this,
uh,
this thing.
Maybe this isn't the same
well crazy beard like Hasidic Jew look or not Hasidic,
but just Yachty wacky beard.
Yeah.
Video videos online.
Talking about it,
about how he used to work in an emergency room and they found that a
disproportionate number of motorcycle victims,
uh,
had tested for this toxoplasma.
Rarely.
Yeah.
That it makes you reckless,
makes you reckless.
It makes you take more chances.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
They don't know exactly what,
what the fuck it's doing to you.
You know,
they don't know exactly like how much of an effect that it has on some people
and other people,
whether it takes over their life,
you know,
but for mice,
it's this fucking death sentence.
They just,
the dicks get hard for campus.
It's the craziest thing ever.
And then they go find them,
these rats and mice.
And if you ever seen the videos of them,
yeah.
It's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
I've run up to the cats.
They're like running up to the cats dick.
It's crazy.
What's the doctor's name that,
that found that,
so Paul Scheme?
Yeah,
he's a Robert Sapolsky tells one of my favorite stories ever talking about
humanity and all that.
He's for 20 some years he's been going to Kenya and studying baboons.
They're always the same.
He's been at the same place for 20 years.
Wow.
And um,
so he's seeing generations come and go.
He is a great book called
the primates,
a memoir,
beautiful book about his years in Kenya.
That's him.
And he's a great writer.
Yeah.
That's in there.
And a pimp.
So he got us and give a fuck.
Yeah,
he's great.
I'm a grooming.
Yeah.
I mean he shoots these baboons with blowguns.
Oh my God.
And then he like gets a bad mugs.
Yeah.
Triangle goes in and does blood tests on there.
Uh,
he's particularly interested in the neurobiology of stress.
So he's looking at like how different males in different points of the hierarchy
you experience stress and stuff.
So,
um,
anyway,
so the story is that he's been,
he's watched all these generations come and go and,
and the baboons troop is very male dominated and they're very,
the males are very fierce and they,
they sort of,
you know,
they're nasty to the females into each other and everything.
So in the years he'd been going there,
they,
the Messiah built a hotel for tourists and this tourist that,
this hotel has a dump and his baboons troops started going to this dump cause
there's good food there and the best food,
of course he's meat scraps of meat that are thrown out by the hotel.
So the dominant males tend to get that meat.
Nobody else gets any.
So one time they threw out some meat that was tainted with tuberculosis and the
upper echelon of this baboons male dominance hierarchy got wiped out.
Whoa.
It was like a bomb went off in Washington or something.
And so he was like,
Whoa,
now what's going to happen?
This is going to be horrible.
Because when the males reach adulthood,
they shift out into a different group.
They go out,
they leave their natal group and they go looking for another group.
So these new males are going to come in full of testosterone looking to kick ass
and there won't be anyone here to fight them off.
It's going to be like pirates landing on an island with no men on it,
you know?
And but what happened was the new males came in.
In the meantime,
the group developed a much more egalitarian,
low stress way of life.
And when the new males came in,
they adopted this new way of life.
Whoa.
So five years later it last,
I heard from him five years later,
this group,
this troop of baboons was still significantly less uptight than any other truth
that has ever been studied.
Isn't that hilarious?
That sort of mirrors America that if you could like poison the military
industrial complex was like sacred caviar from,
see now we're back to the Unabomber.
Right?
I'm not defending him.
I'm just saying there is because he was,
he was going after fucking scientists and professors.
He's a nut.
If it is like senators,
he would've been fine.
It's like that quote that no one ever wants to get heard saying.
Well Hitler had a couple of good ideas.
Exactly.
And so I mean most people that are,
you know,
uh,
young folks,
people that have regular jobs,
people that are out there sort of tuned in and connected to the world are very
frustrated by the way this country and the world in general is run because
it's run by this one small group of people all throughout the world that have a
vested interest in keeping it running that way.
And in that situation,
I mean no one's advocating the anybody do this,
but in that situation it really does mirror this babbling society where these
dominator baboons got jacked and then everybody just chill the fuck out.
And then new people came in and they also chilled the fuck out.
Right.
The problem with that,
I mean I,
I tend to agree with you,
but I th I think comedy has the Patriot Act.
You can't even say that shit.
What's that?
I said the problem with that is the Patriot Act.
Even just saying that it was like can get you in trouble.
Yeah.
So I tell,
I tell a bad story and you get thrown in prison and this,
this is going really well so far.
It's a very good story though.
But what I was going to say is that I'm a little less hopeful than you are in
the sense that I think even if the upper echelon of the,
you know,
the male baboons got wiped out,
we'd probably end up right back where we are because of there's too many people.
Yeah.
There's too many people,
that's for sure.
But there's,
um,
there's not too many people.
If everybody stops jacking each other and stealing resources,
If we don't engage in the,
the,
I mean our culture is essentially a war culture.
I mean,
that's just what it is.
When we're constantly involved,
these oversee conflicts,
controlling parts of the world that we don't really have any business in.
We have military presence in something like a hundred different countries.
I mean we're,
we're crazy and that's a lot of money.
That's a lot of taxes.
A lot of shit.
And if we weren't spending it on that and we were instead spending on some sort
of sustainability,
I mean if you could get the direct proportion amount of money that's spent
waging war and spend that same amount of money trying to enhance the life of
people that are in shit situations,
we would have an exponentially more beautiful world to live in.
And the same amount of money would still be circling around.
It's not like industry couldn't exist if it wasn't for war.
That's nonsense.
That's just something we've been told by the people that are controlling where
we go and what we,
yeah,
but isn't war uniquely profitable in that you're destroying very expensive
stuff,
whether it's the infrastructure of a country or your own munitions,
you know,
1 million bucks a pop for a Predator drone strike or something like that,
that always needs to be replenished.
Right.
Whereas if you're building,
you know,
TV's or chairs or,
or you know,
jerk off cans or whatever it is that,
you know,
there's a certain number that you build and then like that's all anyone needs
for awhile.
Yeah.
So I think there's a builtin impetus to blow shit up cause then you get paid to
rebuild it.
That's the Halliburton ideology.
Exactly.
I don't know about that.
I mean
certainly seems that that's something that goes on.
I mean that certainly seems to be fueling a lot of the activity that we do,
but I don't crave that that's necessary.
I don't know if you fly over the country just one time,
you realize how much open space there really is.
You know?
And that's not just here,
that's like that.
There's the,
I mean the idea of overpopulation is mostly based around the fact that 80% of
our people live near water.
You know,
if we figured out a way to make our lives more sustainable,
to make cities more sustainable,
to pollute less,
and had all the people that are involved in all this nonsense over seas and
dedicated to doing that,
we wouldn't be as reliant on foreign oil.
We wouldn't be as reliant on all these things that we need in these other
places.
Sure.
It's just,
we're just,
we're governed in a shitty way.
And we're governed in this,
this representative way that where nobody feels connected to the actual
decisions that are being made vaguely connected
cause he was being represented.
Let's be serious.
It's corporations are being represented.
The rest of us,
it's wasn't Zappa who said politics is the entertainment division of the
military industrial complex.
That's brilliant.
That night.
Oh,
Zappa was brilliant.
And what a great quote.
Yeah.
And that,
until that becomes,
until puments actually get a say in everything that happens until the United
States gets to
vote on our activities is the thing,
you know,
there's so many fucking people.
It's to manage this many people.
I think the systems that work are dehumanizing,
inherently dehumanizing.
I think that there's a question of scale that it seems to be,
um,
you know,
it just sort of makes sense.
If you're talking to 10 people,
you know,
each of those people gets a 10th of your attention.
If you're talking to 100 million people,
you know,
nobody's getting your attention.
Right,
right.
And,
and so I think there's sort of a mathematical,
almost like a quality of life,
uh,
like,
a limited quality of life.
And the more people there are,
the more people are taking a little piece of it and the smaller the pieces get,
you know,
that's fascinating.
But then how could I,
if that's the case,
then how come some people are just fucking living high on the hog?
Well,
that's the people,
you know,
we're talking about this upper echelon,
right?
The people who meet in Davos or whatever,
You know,
in Switzerland,
oh,
those guys meet in the builder Burger type character kind of thing.
Um,
I,
I've known some of those people,
not a lot.
I've known some people who very,
very up in the world and they're no happier than anybody else,
man.
You know?
And I think a lot of them are actually less happy because happiness isn't about
being able to buy whatever you want.
You know,
I mean,
that wears out.
It is,
unless you're in a great neighborhood and you have good friends and you know a
good escort agency,
if you have all that,
you know,
are we going into a commercial here?
No,
we don't.
We're not represented.
But anything.
Escort agencies.
Yes.
Hollow.
Exactly.
Yeah.
The idea that the richest people are the happiest people is ridiculous.
The another Herzog of video that I really enjoyed was life in the Thai girl.
Happy People.
It's called the happy be a bowl of life and the Taco.
Ah,
no,
I haven't smelled Siberia.
These people that live up in Siberia in the Eagle hunters.
No,
no,
that's a,
that's in Tibet actually.
Siberia is a,
the life and the Taiga people are these trappers that live in this very small
town where they essentially don't use money.
They trap and they take the money from trapping and that's what buys like tools
and equipment and shit.
And you know,
the usage of trade for different things.
But all they do is hunt and fish.
They hunt,
they fish,
they grow food and they're,
they're so happy.
And the men,
they disappear in the winter to go trapping.
They take snowmobiles,
they drive like a fucking hundred miles in a snowmobile and when they come back,
everybody's happy.
They have these celebrations that dogs run behind them when they come back and
the dogs don't make it tough shit.
And these people have like no mental illness.
They're were all happy.
They're all like cheering and dancing and singing.
It really makes you wonder,
like when you look at us,
you know people are sitting on their couch.
Oh,
I'm so bummed out.
Right.
So depressed.
Like for what?
What are you bummed out about?
Like you don't have to do anything right now.
Like you are in a position right now where you can actually relax.
Let's see.
That's it.
He's bummed.
Cause he doesn't have to do anything right now.
Not The problem.
There's no meaning.
It's like there's meaning and food.
When you grow it,
like we're talking about marijuana.
There's meaning when you're smoking bud that you grew and you cut and trimmed
and you cured.
It's like you love,
if you make your own beer,
your own wine,
you cook your own dinner,
whatever it is,
right.
I went hunting recently.
I killed a deer and I've been eating this deer for the past four months and when
I eat it,
I feel like a sense of satisfaction was a lot of effort.
We go like hiking in Montana and camping outside and 12 degrees and I got this
thing.
It's like,
it's like such a much better connection than going to the store and just,
yeah,
picking on a steak.
Yeah.
We still have all these reward systems set up from hunter gatherer cultures
done.
That's it.
And the problem that the sort of the,
the ultimately destructive conundrum at the heart of civilization is that it
leads us to where we think we want to go,
but it isn't really where we should be.
It isn't really the place that's going to make us happy.
Right,
right.
Like everyone thinks if you win the lottery,
you're going to be happy.
Look at studies of people who've actually won the lottery.
Their lives get destroyed in short order.
That's because they don't know me.
I can hook them up there.
They're hanging around with the wrong people.
They're staying in the same neighborhood.
They didn't change their name.
The first thing you do,
you take all that money and going to Canada,
right to,
can I go to Toronto where nobody knows you and he party,
Bitch,
star partying.
You got how much money?
Oh Man.
You just need an organizer.
You just need someone to monitor.
You want $300 million you were,
we're going to make you happy,
dude.
Yeah,
and then he'd get him enrolled in Yoga classes,
keep his brain sharp,
you know,
give him crossword puzzles to do.
This is going to be okay.
We'll take care of you for $100 million will take care of the problem with those
dudes as they stay in Georgia.
The chick filets fuck themselves.
They fall apart.
You can become happier when you win the lottery.
You just got to get hooked up with the right people.
It's possible,
but in general,
that's not what happened.
No,
you can't.
You can't appreciate all joking aside.
You can appreciate things unless you earned them.
You know,
you really,
you know,
you,
if I joked about it once when I was younger,
that the amount of work involved to become a standup comedian,
it's so,
so difficult to go from in the beginning where you just suck too.
Being a competent standup comedian,
that the idea of doing it all again is absolutely terrifying.
It's terrifying.
And I would have never done it if I hit the lottery,
like I would hit the lottery,
who knows 21 and I have millions of dollars,
where would my ambition goal,
where would wear?
And then with that gone also there's like the character lessons,
then failing and then you know,
awkward moments and in social situations,
all the different,
various little bits of information that you use to sort of formulate your own
personality and view of the world.
Those wouldn't exist,
right?
They would exist in a completely different form.
Right?
Because you wouldn't be struggling to make your way through the world with
insecurity like most of us have.
You would all sudden have fucking $300 million would be in your underwear,
in a yacht.
Like you're in a JC video.
You would just keep going until the wheels fell off.
But the other thing is you wouldn't really have any friends because if you,
if you,
if you're just a regular person and people hang out with you,
you can be pretty sure they're hanging out with you because they like hanging
out with you.
Right.
If you just won the lottery and people are hanging out with you on your yacht in
the year z video,
you know why those people are there.
That's true.
But I've heard that argument before about like being a celebrity,
like people just like you just because you know,
how do you know when people actually like you?
You can kind of tell when people like it.
Yeah.
But that's,
cause you're,
you've been through it.
Yeah.
And if you come up in that world,
yeah,
well you can definitely,
you'll definitely see people that are bullshitting,
you know,
for sure.
I mean,
if you just won $300 million,
he's going to have,
you're going to have some good friends,
you know,
how are you?
Oh my God.
We would celebrate.
It.
Next thing you know,
someone's trying to fucking look at you like you're a puzzle.
I kind of figured out a way in this mother fucker and get some,
extract some money off of this pitch.
Now the people will look at you like that if you were some dude who just,
especially if you just got lucky,
it's one thing if you're some crazy fuck starts a landscaping business and owns
a hundred different,
you know,
fucking warehouse is filled with lawn mowers and you're sending people out
everyday.
You know what I mean?
You like plus your ass and then created an empire.
That's one thing.
Like you respect that guy.
Yeah.
People won't immediately,
if they know that you're,
you know,
Lenny the landscape or king,
they,
they don't,
they don't go after you,
but if your some,
you're Lenny the fucking Douche bag.
It was working in a lottery king.
Yeah.
He's working at cvs and all of a sudden scratched the right ticket.
Boom.
They will go after you.
You don't deserve it.
They're like,
fuck that guy.
You just got to get your money's worth from everyone and that girls,
you know,
just really used them all day long,
but it's not girls or they're going to go after you.
It's business people.
It's a lot of people like,
come,
I got this business,
I'm going
to get started.
You know how many times people would come up to me and want to start a business
and I'm so,
it's such a ridiculous idea,
but I'm always like,
not,
I'm not going into business with you.
We're not,
we're not starting a business together.
Like what the fuck are you talking about?
How you might go to a bank pitch,
there's money in there.
They have money.
You go and you sign out some papers.
You get alone.
The crazy ass this thing,
years ago,
like 10 years ago,
this guy,
he didn't win the lottery,
but he inherited like $20 million.
His parents had a farming business or something that is the lottery,
so he inherits $20 million.
He's like 24 years old or something.
And he gets a few friends together and they fly to Monaco and he's like,
yeah,
he's going to celebrate with a wild weekend in Monaco with five or six of his
friends.
Four days later,
all $20 million was gone.
Whoa.
Lost it all.
Oh my God.
Days.
Monaco.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
So they said to him,
how did it happen?
And he said,
well,
gradually at first and suddenly at the end,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Sums it up,
doesn't it man?
Wow,
that is insanity.
Well,
you can go insane gambling.
That's one of the,
uh,
the arguments for gambling being illegal.
I do.
I don't support that argument.
I don't agree with it whatsoever.
I'm a 100% proponent of personal freedom,
but I'm in personal responsibility.
But I've seen people get that crazy gambling I,
and it's a sickness and it's to exploit that sickness.
It's like,
I mean,
it's akin to having sex with a girl is passed out for being drunk.
That's exploiting that.
It really all exploding the Gambler,
right?
Who's that sick and over the end.
And just like letting him continue to gamble.
Like someone needs to come.
I'm not aiming.
No,
because I believe in personal responsibility.
but realistically,
if you were like eve had any ethics whatsoever and he saw some guys about to bet
$20 million,
you know,
he would go,
hey,
yeah,
this is not a good time.
Okay,
you moved to my neighborhood,
my friends Tom down.
Okay,
I need one thing to play a little black Jack thousand dollar hand here or there.
Let's get crazy and give yourself a fucking women.
You're about to lose $20 million in a day.
Uh,
stop it.
So it sounds to me like you've got the same sort of career ambitions I have.
What does that,
which is to hang out with really wealthy people and help them not fuck up.
I mean,
I had this dream of like,
I was going to be like the psychiatrist too,
you know,
like I'll just,
I'll be a psych nurse psychologist too.
Like,
you know,
movies.
George Clooney would be much better off if I would hang out at his house.
Know you say that,
and it's kind of a funny thing,
but in,
in other cultures,
they mean throughout history there's,
there have been wise men that hung around great men that her advice.
Yeah,
definitely.
Especially men who are like big
and,
you know,
and back in the day,
conquerors even would,
would,
would have a sit down with scholars and they would discuss certain issues.
It was like important to sort of be surrounded by people like that.
But in this sort of society,
it's sort of gone the way of the Shaman that there's no Shamans,
there's no scholars in your midst.
Just know,
you know,
just intellectual that you keep handy.
Now we have Google,
we don't need that guy anymore.
Right.
But,
but,
but wisdom,
you know,
and especially wisdom and response to personal issues.
Yeah.
Right.
We have it.
I guess personal coaching is sort of got away.
Yeah.
No,
no,
seriously.
I'm talking about the modern rendition,
you know,
like people who are your personal code,
like life coaches,
life coaches.
Here's my example with a life coach.
There was a guy who was a,
I am fascinated by um,
women who always successful women who always date losers and a,
I've seen quite a few examples of it.
It's really fascinating to me,
you know,
to watch this weird dynamic when there's a really successful woman and a guy who
who's essentially a fuck up just to total fuckup.
Well this guy was a,
he was a nanny to this really successful woman,
a male nanny.
And my friend who like knows the family was like,
what the fuck is that?
Oh that's not going to end well of course,
doesn't that unwell?
She winds up dumping her boyfriend and hooking up with a male nanny.
So then the male nanny is living in the house,
like the big house where he was like taking care of the kids.
He's the boyfriend now and now he's a life coach and Hellboy out of nowhere the
nannies,
a fucking life coach.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
like there's some fuckery of foot.
And now that household,
this someone is just like,
that's like a guy who like essentially like a two or three steps removed from
being a con artist and he's managed to fit himself into this semi legit
situation where he's got this for poor,
confused rich lady.
So is he coaching his clients to get jobs,
families for poor kids are for rich ladies.
I've resisted getting close to them in like conversations at parties and stuff
like that because I don't trust myself.
I don't trust my sexually.
No,
but I like a chimpanzee rage.
You might say something.
I made freaked out.
I might,
uh,
he's,
he's gross.
I,
I've had a conversation with the guy wants before and it was just like,
whoa.
Like he's just,
he's just gross.
It's just speaking of chimpanzee rage or do want to continue on and how gross
that was.
Just going to say it.
There's like certain people you talk to and um,
they're like,
uh,
if you ever like been around someone who literally was like a Hollywood
character,
like in a movie,
we're like literally just like completely fake.
Like if pulling your pants down to the crack,
your ass was in there going to do it.
Yeah.
That was this guy.
And he's just like this,
it was like this,
almost like a,
a,
an alien that was taking on the form of a human,
you know,
he was so Hollywood.
I mean he had the,
he had like everything you could ask for.
He had beads,
like wouldn't beat it.
Necklace and you know,
it was Harrison,
a ponytail.
I wanted to throw him through the universe.
It was just everything about him.
And then the fact that I found out that this guy had a hookup,
dealt with the lady.
And then you're friends with the lady?
No,
I don't know the lady at all.
no.
The,
the,
the ladies,
it's just this old broad that we know
Angela Lansbury was older than him.
She's old enough.
She looks,
there's a lot to this story that I'm going to have to get personal if I keep
going any further.
I don't want it.
Yeah,
that's all right Rick.
He's a good guy.
I feel terrible.
Something Ricky was on the pocket.
I never think,
I never,
I've never included his name until right now.
When I told that story,
he would tell that story.
It's writing.
I just don't want it.
And he would laugh about how his wife would never let him read that.
Yeah.
I mean,
I had a great time talk.
That's why it was memorable.
It's like,
wow,
this guy is cool.
And he was going to come play poker with us and like do this basketball thing
and he was going to come,
let's go.
I didn't care if we don't do the project together,
but why didn't he call me?
And his wife's a wonderful lady.
She just,
she's just got her thing,
you know,
everybody's got their shit together.
It works.
I'm not judging some,
you're talking about reactions to the book,
right?
Brian?
Brian's girlfriend who didn't like the book,
right?
Um,
or didn't like the idea of the moon.
We've had so many really personal responses to the,
it's so people either,
you know,
they respond to it positively or negatively,
but it's very personal.
Sexuality is very personal.
The idea that,
um,
you're fucked up because you're,
you're attracted to other people.
Right.
That's,
that's very personal too because it's sort of a secret that a lot of people
harbor around inside them.
Sure,
sure.
Some people,
women have written,
it was lots of women,
uh,
to say that they had to stop every 10 pages and masturbate.
Oh,
what a good girl.
Yeah.
What a good girl.
I did not see that one coming,
so to speak.
Wow.
I never fantasize that by the way,
they also masturbate while watching Max and rules while they're eating cheerios.
It was a freak bitch.
It's every 10 minutes,
no matter what they're doing.
This is what,
this one in a million that have just liked that period no matter what that,
um,
uh,
exactly.
That's,
uh,
it's,
it's such a,
an interesting subject because of that fact because of the fact that our society
is set up to sort of um,
create this image that gives us these,
these positive sort of feelings inside of our brain when we watched them in a
movie or on a television show or even hear about them in a song,
but they don't necessarily represent reality.
But our brain is not set up for the media.
Our brain is not set up for the influence of television or a movie.
Our brain is set up to imitate successful behavior and we're selling,
we're,
we're set up to sort of learn from our environment.
But we have this new now and it's 60 feet high and the fucking words are perfect
because a team of writers worked on what Brad Pitt was going to say for like two
weeks before he actually said it.
I mean it was like really meticulously done down to the exact comma and then
it's music is playing.
Why saying the perfect thing and your version of reality all of a sudden has a
new model and your version is based on bullshit.
Sandra Bullock's life was not a Sandra Bullock movie.
Right.
Think about how every Sandra Bullock movie is like this sweet thing and you
know,
monogamy rules and it all works out in the end.
Me and mom,
she was married to Jessie fucking James Guy with tattoos all over his body.
He was banging and everything like a savage.
It's like your friend with the old lady,
your friend.
Sorry.
He was using Sandra boot company.
No,
I bet he really loved her.
I bet he's a damaged dude and a bet.
He really loves pussy.
I bet that too.
Yeah.
I don't think he was using it.
I don't know though.
I don't assume.
I know.
It's like that's why people hated him because he was like some unknown guy who
was screwing the soup.
Everybody's baby.
You know,
everybody probably liked him.
she probably liked it.
I mean she couldn't,
when you like a guy,
even if he's like a deceptive guy,
like that guy,
he's just,
there's obviously something about him that she must have liked and what she
must've enjoyed his company couldn't have all been fake.
I mean,
you can say it was,
but what is it?
Okay when,
but someone's inspired around a person,
they act differently or act better.
Is that fake too?
I mean,
there's a you,
are you a fake because you're better or you fake because you know you like
someone so much that you aspire to be kinder around them,
are nicer around them.
Is that,
I don't know if that's fake and I,
I don't know the dude,
but I know that her life,
you know,
her movies were all these really beautiful,
sweet movies that give you a warm feeling that it's all going to work out.
And then her whole life was,
that life was,
she was,
he was fucking that crazy girl with their fucking tat was tattooed on her
forehead.
We talked about it yesterday.
We thought she,
you thought she had Nazi tattoos,
but there's just no egos.
No,
she did.
she has WP on her leg
right here on her,
her,
uh,
on her throat.
She has the little Nazi symbol and yeah,
there was like a lot of people that found photos of it.
Oh really?
Okay.
That might not be real.
You got to be careful about that shit.
You can't show you cute.
It's funny that the swastika used to be like a symbol of good luck still is in
Tibet and Nepal.
They still use it now.
That's a bold,
yeah.
I saw this guy,
uh,
in Bangkok,
first time I was in Bangkok in the late eighties,
this guy tie guy wanted to open a bar that would attract tourists cause you can
make more money from tourists obviously.
So he's looking in old life magazines to try to get a motif that foreigners
would relate to.
And he came across a photos of the Nazis.
Uh,
he,
he didn't know what was going on.
He didn't know about World War II.
He was like completely out of touch with us.
But he liked the imagery.
So he did up his bar and all this Nazi images.
Oh,
not not thinking it was
going to attract the foreigners.
Right.
Cause he was in this foreign
opening night did not go as planned.
It's crazy because you can go back far enough and you can rock that.
Like you could get Gingiss con shit and put it all.
Nobody would have to do all in with that.
Yeah.
You could go back to like Alexander the Great,
you know,
if you could find like,
you know some Alexander the great memorabilia,
but if you have any Nazi memorabilia in your house,
that's a no,
no,
no.
You can't have anything.
You can't have a hat,
a gun,
you can't have anything with an ass ass.
You can't have anything like it's too quick.
It's too,
you know,
even though it was 1947 or whatever it was when it ended still too close.
I mean you mentioned chimp rage earlier and it reminded me of something I was
thinking when I was watching your special,
which by the way,
I'm sure you don't need me to plug it,
but anyone who hasn't downloaded that thing should not consider themselves a
true fan.
Fantastic.
Thank you man.
I'm glad.
It was really,
really good.
Thank you.
Um,
and,
and then of course I put it up on bittorrent.
Yeah.
Throw it out there.
It's great.
Our magazine and it shows that Jesse James,
Mr [inaudible] with the swastika.
Oh,
is that really a swastika in the center of that bird wears it on her neck.
right.
Let's close up.
Oh,
wow.
That's dark.
Ooh,
that's a really painful place,
right,
to get a tattoo.
Right.
Well,
she's got one on her forehead,
man.
Yeah.
Other than that,
just kind of on a dirty way.
You're,
um,
but my,
my point being that we have these,
uh,
you know,
where I started before this,
the,
we have these,
a reward system set up for being hunters and gatherers and they're sort of
hijacked by movies and TV.
And when something comes along,
like your book where it,
uh,
pretty much just factually breaks down the history of sexuality.
And what I thought was really interesting is one of the things about the word
promiscuous and the origins of the word promiscuous,
it meant mixed and that we look at it as some sort of loose morals and some we
have attached to this sort of judgment to it and when in fact the idea of
promiscuity of today fucking strangers really didn't even exist in these
cultures.
Right.
Everybody knew each other.
That gets us back to where we were saying earlier about numbers they get,
it kind of does come down to raw numbers.
At a certain point.
You remember Robin Dunbar's number?
Did you get to that one 50 right?
Yeah,
I'd heard about that before actually.
They talked about it on the podcast,
but I have a real issue with remembering people's names.
Right.
I can,
I can recall crazy shit from fights that happened 15 years ago while we're
Brian.
I have a really good retention of information,
but at a certain point in time,
like I ran out of room for people's names and I felt it.
I actually felt it happen right now where it's like,
and people will,
you'll,
you'll meet someone you don't remember what their fucking name is and then they
tell you and then all their,
their file pops up again like it was on temporary delete and you'll all of a
sudden you have access.
Oh yeah,
you're Billy's brother.
Okay.
And then all
of his file like fills back in.
And do you like forget people's names as you're hearing them?
Like at a party or something?
I said to,
unless I'm paying attention,
I try not to do that because it's rude,
you know?
Does that weird thing that happens when you,
you know,
you're at a party and you're meeting like 10 people and it's like,
it's overloaded.
It's really hard to like put them all into a file,
you know,
almost want to write it down.
Okay.
Bob,
assume you're saying,
okay.
Yeah,
take a picture of your box.
Okay.
Thank you.
There's an APP for that day.
Then he'd be like looking at his phone when he came back to talk to you.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Mom,
pick up where we left off.
Yeah.
Can I take notes on our conversation?
Just so you,
but you're the NASA guy.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was saying earlier that when I was watching your show,
I was thinking about something and maybe you can respond to it like you watching
you like the way you prowl onstage.
I had this,
I thought,
man,
that's a comedian who could kick my ass.
And I don't,
I can't think of any other comedian who I've re,
you know,
are there tough comedians?
I don't know.
I really,
comedians are Sorta,
you know,
I thought,
um,
and when I first started working for the UFC,
I thought it would,
I never brought it up on stage and I thought maybe this was like,
we're really good if people don't know about this.
Like on stage,
I never,
never on stage have ever talked about martial arts or anything that I've ever
done.
Like physically,
right.
Until the UFC became so big.
Like in the,
uh,
the,
the mid two thousands,
after like 2005,
it was sort of inevitable at that point.
But before then,
like I would never talk about martial arts on stage it and the humor Da.
Yeah,
yeah.
Because I looked like a meathead anyway.
You know,
I just,
I,
you know,
I look,
if I didn't know me and I would guess like what would come out of my mouth,
I'd be like,
this fucking idiot.
What's he going to talk about?
Protein or we can talk about,
well how much creatine you take.
Stupid would,
I would,
I would make fun of myself.
So it's automatic that I think people make fun of me or that they would discount
me as a comedian,
you know?
But that's just the way I look.
Like,
you know,
it's nothing I can do about it.
My interests have always been in martial arts.
I can't help it.
I mean,
I'm still completely fascinated and dedicated to the art of standup comedy.
I love doing it.
It's my favorite thing to do on in life.
But I like martial arts too.
Like why?
It's a weird thing we're supposed to like hide that in some way.
But as a comedian,
I think you've,
you've transcended it watches what I noticed and it's like,
wow,
there's something inherently contradictory about,
yeah,
a tough,
you know,
type a Alpha male comedian.
It's not funny cause that's a guy,
you know,
that it's,
there are two roles in conflict.
Well,
you pull it off and somehow or another,
it will also like people.
Um,
the beautiful thing about having a podcast like this is the podcast popularity
came right after the UFC,
his popularity and with the podcast,
essentially,
there's nowhere to hide.
This is who you are,
right?
When they talk,
when you're talking for four hours,
or what did we do yesterday,
four and a half hours with Bert Kreischer,
everybody knows who you are.
That's,
that's you.
You're that guy.
You're that guy as good or bad.
You know,
at that point they're hanging out with you.
Yes.
It's not edited.
Right.
Do you have a friend?
Like I have a friend,
my friend John Rollo and John Rawls,
great guy,
but he's one of the scariest fucking human beings you've ever seen in your
fucking life.
He's,
he's built at least about 300 pounds of solid muscle.
It's ridiculously big guy.
And honest chest has a tattoo of an angel choking a devil unconscious.
Okay.
And then he's a frightening man.
His arms or I'm not bullshitting.
There's maybe three.
You've seen John Rollo,
but three of my arms,
his arms are probably like three of my arms.
And he's a Brazilian jujitsu black belt was his big giant dude.
But everybody who knows him when you're around him,
he's a sweetie.
He's got like a bunch of cats and he said the gentlest guy you'd ever want to be
around.
So when you're around them and he's saying funny shit,
you laugh because you know John.
But if you met John at a restaurant,
he started laughing.
He's like,
is he laughing before he just fucking snaps,
kills everybody in this place.
You know what I'm saying?
Like once you get to know him,
then it doesn't matter that this big giant scary dude,
he's just John,
you know,
just hanging with John.
So I think that is allowed me to sneak in because I,
I,
I did other things because of a fear factor.
UFC stuff.
People got to know me already,
so they like accepted a certain amount of the weird,
you know,
but yeah,
as a comedian you're sort of always thought like,
you don't want to go Joe Polish kapow style.
Right.
Joe Piscopo was like on the cover of muscle and fitness,
fucking flexing.
And that was like the end.
Really.
Like everybody's like,
you can't be like a bodybuilder and be funny and like get Outta here.
So,
well,
you know,
I mean,
it's interesting because maybe one of the reasons I noticed it,
as I said to you,
I was living,
I had been living in Spain for 20 years,
right.
So I didn't know anything about fear factor or UFC or none of that stuff is like
on my radar.
Right.
I'm in Barcelona,
I don't,
I don't have and I don't have cable or whatever.
Um,
so yeah,
it was like seeing it all for the first time.
It was interesting.
Yeah.
Well you doing in Spain for 20 years growing weed.
That's it.
Just growing weed in Spain.
I'm joking.
Uh,
uh,
lots of different things.
You know,
it was teaching some English.
I was a translating editing.
Um,
I worked as an inhouse translator and editor for the biggest porn company in the
world for awhile.
They're based in Barcelona.
Yeah.
I had a Gig as a interpreting from ebonics to English,
if you can believe that for a film festival.
Yeah.
In term like some lighter job
plain,
like the lady on airplanes.
I speak jive.
Exactly.
It's exactly,
that's it.
That's a Gig that's on my resume,
man.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
That's a,
that's so fascinating gig.
Yeah.
Well they're the way.
And then what did you have to interpret?
Like people?
Yeah.
What happened was,
uh,
there's this film festival called in Edit and uh,
it's,
it's independent films,
right?
So this one year they were doing,
uh,
focusing on films about the origins of rock and roll,
rock and roll,
jazz blues in the Delta,
right.
So like old time,
Delta Guitarists,
Delta Blues Guitars,
and also the origins of hip hop in Brooklyn.
In the 70s and so they had a team of like 20 Spanish translators who great and
understood
English very well,
but they couldn't understand these black people.
So,
so first they call up this black dude who was friends with,
with one of the translators and he listened to the stuff and he couldn't
understand either because he's British.
So,
so the one day I get this call from my friend Pinky,
she's like,
Chris,
do you understand black people?
And I had had a black girlfriend for a while.
I thought she meant on some conceptual level,
you know,
like so
it's like,
yeah,
I guess I'm a Shitty Dancer,
but I understand that.
Did you drink like Colt 45 essential,
wait the process and get into the role and moving join go.
Yeah.
What's up?
I'm a method translator now.
So she gave me the DVDs and all I had to do was just watch the DVD and they
would like,
okay,
in this part,
what's he saying there?
And he's like,
Yo,
I'm up my crib man.
Like yeah,
we're going back to my apartment.
Oh,
okay,
good.
And then they do the Spanish.
So I didn't even have to go into Spanish.
That is hilarious.
That's really funny.
Wow.
Yeah.
I've had lots of,
did you ever think of just like throwing in some fake translation is to fuck
with them,
just to be silly and get bored with it?
Yeah.
No,
no.
I was,
I did a good job.
That's hilarious.
So you were over there for 20 years,
did you,
I mean,
everybody says don't,
I'm still over there officially.
Oh,
you really,
you just visiting here.
It's more or less.
I'm,
I'm basically,
I mean,
it sounds so Hollywood,
man.
I'm here to pitch a TV.
Show that to sound a little [inaudible].
I'm gonna lie.
Yeah.
I'm going to,
I'm going to get some beads and put my hair in a ponytail.
I'm going for it.
Uh,
what's the TV show about?
Can you say about sexuality,
sex drive?
Is it like one of those history channel shows?
Well,
I mean,
we'll see what happens.
But the idea channel show is I developed a show in Vancouver this summer with
the friend.
A guy you might know actually,
or at least did you see?
Um,
I am Bruce Lee.
Yes.
He's the director of that.
Okay.
What's his name?
Pete Mccormick.
He also did a great film on Muhammad Ali called facing Holly.
Have you seen that?
That saw the all the guys who will ollifont talk about him?
Exactly.
I heard about it,
but again,
I can't really depresses me.
Watch an old boxer slur depresses the shit out of me.
I really have a problem with it.
Any,
any old athlete,
that's all got issues.
It really bothers me.
So I didn't watch it.
It's a great film.
It's really moving actual beds.
That's very touching because it's,
you know,
you go into it thinking or I went into it thinking,
okay,
it's about boxing.
It's about macho tough ass guys.
It's not man.
It's about love.
It's about charity.
I mean,
Ali,
you still like set up some of the fights,
like the,
not,
not the main contender fights,
but between the title bouts.
You know,
where you fight someone for the title,
but you know the guy gets not going to win.
It's a tuneup match.
Well,
he,
he scheduled some of those to help dudes out.
Like he heard this one guy,
I think he's,
his son had overdosed and his wife committed suicide and he just had this
horror,
he's gone through this horrible period in his life and Ali would be like,
get him.
He's,
you know,
line him up,
talked to his people.
And so he do it to give these guys an infusion to cash.
And Kenny Norton was like living in his car when he fought Ali wasn't real.
Yeah.
It's a really good movie,
man.
It's really,
and,
and uh,
Joe Loo,
uh,
Joe Frazier's,
Joe Louis,
Joe Frazier.
It was like crying at one point.
Wow.
Talking about Ali.
Very interesting pizza.
I said to Pete,
how did you get,
because you don't hear Pete at all.
It's just the people being interviewed,
but they're so vulnerable,
man.
It's really,
it's a beautiful film.
And I said,
how did you get Joe Frazier to be that open about Ali?
Because he hated Ali,
you know,
and uh,
and pizza,
you know,
I said to him,
look,
Joe,
you know,
like,
yeah,
you know,
I know how you feel about the fighting and all that.
But when you look at Alli now as a man,
just as a man,
how do you feel?
What do you think,
you know,
and that they're not really brought it out of Joe Frazier.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It must be weird to go and have conversations with someone about a dude that you
fought this 15 years ago and you're still talking about him,
and people still want to know about it.
Not even 15 years ago.
It's really 25 years ago,
whatever it was.
They thought that was a long fucking time ago.
When,
when did they fight?
They fight in the 70s right?
Yeah.
Well,
he was fighting from the early sixties I think,
wasn't he in the Olympics in [inaudible] 62 maybe?
I think it was 67 to 70 was when they told him all of them.
Yeah.
So,
yeah.
yeah,
so you're talking about 40 fucking plus years ago.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
And Joe Frazier recently died.
He died within a year of doing that interview.
Wow.
But anyway,
so I developed the show with,
with,
uh,
with Pete and the idea of the show is to try to get the same tone of sex at
dawn.
So it's got some scholarly halfed but it's also fun to,
to,
you know,
to be there,
like to read it or to be in the show.
So it's without being juvenile to be playful and,
you know,
an open and,
but,
uh,
without being BBC professorial to be scholarly.
So it's like ancient aliens,
but with sex,
you ever see that show?
I haven't seen that.
Like,
if aliens squirted the alien scored,
not
ancient.
You actually turn your microphone on to say that to,
and at the time of turning in microphone,
you actually still thought it was a good idea.
Um,
no.
yeah.
Ancient aliens is a show.
That's a fascinating show about,
you know,
the idea of influence of,
uh,
aliens on ancient cultures.
Oh,
right,
right.
I know most of it,
by the way.
We should mention it that the guy has that one dude I pass Copans yeah,
yeah.
Unfortunately if you,
uh,
it was only maybe 40 episodes ago,
we interviewed him maybe last Phillip Copans and a really nice guy.
Um,
and he,
he uh,
he passed recently.
He's regularly,
he's an author and he's regularly on,
um,
ancient aliens and unfortunately,
and he found out he had a,
a type of very rare type of lung cancer and within one year finding out or a one
month rather finding out about it,
he was dead.
Wow.
Yeah.
Really scary stuff.
It was like some kind of bacteria infection or something at first.
Yeah.
It's apparently pretty rare,
but a really nice guy.
Really unfortunate.
And the first guy who ever died who do this podcast,
what's the first one who's done the podcast and off?
Not with us anymore.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Nice guy.
Socks.
It wasn't even 40,
I don't think things are 39 or so.
Oh No.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I was imagining a guy in his seventies or,
yeah,
that would be cool.
Yeah.
But an ancient aliens is a,
it's a really fun show because it's,
you know,
they,
they go the what if route.
Most of the time they get pretty deep.
Like a,
Giorgio sucralose is one of the main guys and he's a friend of the podcast he's
been on a few times and he has this fucking be crazy hair.
I don't know if you've ever seen him.
You wouldn't see them.
If you're out there in Spain,
hanging out with those sophisticated people that,
uh,
yeah,
you'll get into this,
this part where it goes,
is it possible?
You know,
that big flood isn't the alien?
And they'll go deep into the,
is it possible to see if you're high and you're watching that show?
And he goes,
is it possible?
You know,
like,
oh my goodness,
where are we going?
I'm thinking of big foot.
Could be in the and are tall.
Well,
they're pretty sure that if there ever was a big foot that it's an animal called
gigantic [inaudible] that did exist.
If you've ever seen the images of it,
it's pretty fascinating because it was essentially exactly what everybody
describes.
And describe a Sasquatch and it lived in Asia and uh,
humans came from Asia.
And we know when we,
when they did the,
one of the ways they found this out was,
could they did a test in the human genome because a guy who was a Mormon,
a devout Mormon,
was convinced that a DNA testing could prove that the,
uh,
the Mormon,
the,
the book of Mormon was actually in fact correct and that human beings did come
from Jerusalem and that all these,
all these American Indians were in the lost tribe of Jesus.
So they did a DNA test on,
I found,
no,
actually most of them are from Siberia.
There,
there a lot of what you're getting and you're getting American Indians.
It's people that came across in the Bering strait.
Sure.
Well,
coincidentally,
that area of the country is the highest area incidents of bigfoot sightings,
the Pacific northwest,
the upper,
the Alaska,
that whole way down.
That's the,
the only play.
I'm not the only place in the country,
but it's like that's where it really started.
That's where people really started seeing these fucking things.
Right.
And that's where they would be.
I mean,
it really kinda makes,
if there really was a,
an undiscovered primate,
it would be in the rain forest or the Pacific northwest.
Right.
It's not outside the realm of possibility.
In fact,
even Jane Goodall,
Jane Goodall's convinced,
she actually said she was convinced that there's an undiscovered primate living
there.
So there's too many people with the same story.
She started slowly.
Yeah,
I didn't know they have sounds that these things have made,
I dunno,
made me,
maybe they existed and maybe they died off.
But if there's a small amount of them,
it's not impossible that they're alive.
If you stop and think about like how rare it is,
the,
you see a bear or a mountain lion and then fucking know there's thousands of
those.
If there was like one area where an animal existed.
But there's a lot of areas in this country where like it's these,
the only,
the only place we can find blank.
You know,
it's really hard to find an alligator outside of Florida and you know,
the,
the south area,
you know,
you don't find alligators too often in Michigan.
Right.
You know,
that's a,
that's a condensed little area.
Boom.
There's where all the alligators are.
This is where the climate is perfect for them.
It's not outside of the realm of possibility.
There's like a fucking crazy monkey that no one's ever found.
It's most likely not the case.
Most likely people are full of Shit.
The problem is they're so big,
they'd be top predators and it would be hard for there to be a sustainable
population of them in,
in that area.
It's true.
You know?
However,
we don't know that there,
we don't know that they're carnivores.
They easily could be plant matter just like elephants are gigantic as well.
It's still worry about the viable genetic material.
How many of them,
I mean you think about like deer,
like let's say dear eve,
there's so infrequently you never see them.
Could they continue as a species?
You know,
we had a less drought from survivor,
man.
What the fuck was that?
We had less trout from survivor man on,
and he told us a story.
He,
he's had to bigfoot sightings.
Oh yeah.
What's it,
what's fascinating about that guy is he's 100% legit.
He's not full of Shit at all.
And uh,
he didn't actually see it,
but,
uh,
he was in his tent and he heard something big walking through is in Alaska,
miles from nowhere.
And it flew in on a plane,
I mean,
hours by plane from everywhere,
you know,
and uh,
he heard something bipedal walking through the woods,
something really heavy.
And then it was like 50 feet from his 10.
It starts going,
Ooh,
it makes us crazy.
Primate noise.
And he struggles to EEG.
He scrambles to get his camera and then it runs off.
And so he doesn't know what the fuck it is,
but he knows it was really heavy.
And it sounded like an ape,
you know,
it's not likely to,
if they haven't found these things.
Footprints.
I don't,
I don't think so.
I think it was too cold an owl in a tree and some kind of land creature walking
up to get the owl,
the owl freaks out,
flies away instead of this thing.
And yeah,
it could be,
but it doesn't sound that loud.
And it doesn't sound like an ape,
you know,
unless we're there,
it's all,
it's all bullshit.
Who knows?
He might have had some fucking mushroom that he found under a log and just
trimming the holes off.
I'm not saying that it's,
it's legit,
but if you see the scientific depiction of a gigantic pith agus pull,
pull that image of there's,
um,
there's,
there's one online,
but they have a reproduction of this thing and it lived alongside humans for
sure the minimum a hundred thousand years ago,
but it could have been alive more than that or sooner than that.
They,
they got photo bones of this thing and like a Chinese medicine shop was the
first time they found him.
And like some anthropologists had gotten a hold these bonds,
like what the fuck is this from?
And they,
they apparently from there realized that there was a,
it was a primate tooth and it was a primary tooth that didn't fit with the known
species.
And so that initiated the search for this animal.
Right.
But when you see the image of gigantic Pacifica us,
it's,
it's essentially exactly what a big foot is.
It's an now where does the aquatic eight fit into all the aquatic ape theory is
the theory of like that's a gigantic [inaudible],
right?
I mean that's a real animal.
Okay.
And that's from how long ago is absolutely a hundred thousand years more
recently than that.
It gets sketchy.
It,
it's funny,
it looks like an orangutan,
but I sent him right because it's too heavy to swing from trees and it doesn't
give a fuck.
You know,
imagine how strong that thing would be if you stop and think about the fact that
150 pound champ as,
as strong as a 500 pound man.
What is a 2000 pound primate?
What kind of strength is that?
I mean,
a gorilla can literally rip you apart like tissue paper.
What does,
what can that thing and bloats and ozone and,
yeah,
and it's tough.
You up it's ass in little pieces.
That's what a gorilla can do.
Just shred you down into little tampon size pieces and stuff.
You up his ass,
this thing.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's recently,
um,
as 100,000 years ago.
That's fact.
But there's,
um,
there's speculation that they may have lived a much more recent than that.
There's a lot of different,
you,
I'm sure,
you know,
there's a lot of different species where they thought it was extinct and they
found out that,
that there's one coelacanth that crazy fish with the legs.
It looks like,
it looks like a prehistoric fish.
Weird like extensions to,
it's like fins pulled one up from in the forties or something.
Yeah.
And they were like,
oh,
we thought these things were long dead.
But uh,
it's patently ridiculous when it comes to the ocean.
There's so little of the ocean that we really have a firm grip on,
but they found the tooth in,
um,
in 1935 in the apothecary shop.
It was a fossilized bone.
And that's a,
that's the,
I guess they used them in traditional Chinese medicine.
So they've been grinding up these fucking bones of this thing forever.
Chinese medicine.
It's hilarious.
Chinese medicine in the leg or penises bear gallbladders and I mean,
what is that?
Is that when the shit is that psychological shit,
they're doing area placebo effect and there may be some effect and some things,
but I mean come on at Tiger Penis isn't gonna make you horny?
Well,
yeah,
I think it will.
It's um,
there's so much of that need for faith and belief in fate in the entire Chinese
culture,
especially in regards to martial arts.
Like China has been around for,
I mean,
think about how long Chinese culture that dates back that we understand me
thousands and thousands of years.
A very sophisticated culture.
Yeah.
They have the most dog shit martial artists in the world.
There are martial arts are almost entirely useless.
Really?
Yeah.
They have very few martial arts where there's like legitimate techniques that
would work in a situation against them trained fighter because it hasn't been
adapted.
They're not good.
They're just like clunky,
like,
like Real Kung Fu.
Like you're pretending to be like animals and shit like that.
That is not the way to fight.
It doesn't,
it doesn't work.
You know there's like,
there's like there's established like now because of the ultimate fighting
championship is very clear parameters of what is and isn't effective against the
best fighters in the world.
There's just no kung fu in that.
There's a guy named Roy Nelson,
it says the Kung Foo fighter,
but really just knocks people out.
But he's in a lot of Kung fu about fatal blows,
like ripping your eyes out or taking your,
your throat out.
Then she doesn't really work.
You can poke people in the eyes.
Definitely no doubt about it.
He can't really rip someone's throat out.
You can try.
It's not going to go.
I said,
it's so hard to rip out a throat.
You know,
like to think that you're just going to go in there like fucking Billy Jack
movie or Patrick Swayze at roadhouse.
Right.
You know that guy's going to be punching in the face while you're holding onto
his neck.
He keeps not that easy to use crabs on it and I can pull it out.
Right then.
The people would be doing that all the time and it'd be like the number one
cost.
Dad ripped the balls off,
either kick somebody in the balls,
it hurts.
But if they're filled up with adrenaline,
they're going to still attack you.
The idea that you're going to debilitate someone by kicking him in the balls if
he's a pussy,
but it can't survive if someone's trying to kill you.
I just say you kicked me in the balls I'm debilitated would also never be an
attacker or similar and would have to care.
Right.
You lost your deck.
Better chance just tickling the person in with a chance thing that ticklish.
Yeah man.
A lot of people,
I think probably if you were a,
if you were trying to tickle them they would would fucking freak the fuck out.
Or you see particularly set out sir.
No,
he's not.
You look at this size.
This is the,
um,
the actual size of a gigantic pickets in relationship to him.
Man.
G Blackie is what they call Blackie is the,
the actual full scientific name.
Okay,
well it's 1930 the name that's fucking about,
you know,
there's dirty bitches.
You know Quentin Tarantino's going to be making a movie about this.
Oh no you didn't.
Yeah,
I saw that movie last night.
What'd you think?
It's very good movie,
man.
I mean it's the,
the,
the use of the word nigger is so prevalent in that movie.
It's kind of preposterous at a certain point in time.
You're like,
okay,
I really like,
did you have to say it this many times?
But the reality has,
have you thought about it?
Like that's probably how they communicated.
That's what he says.
As authentic as it gets.
But that aside,
it's a fucking great movie.
Yeah,
it's good.
Some really funny moments.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker and almost every one of his movie.
Yeah,
it's gigantic.
I think blocking and then ridiculous.
You uncreative fuckheads from 1930
did you read it and don't know if you remember in the book we talk about
Drapetomania,
which was the disease of black,
who had the pathological desire not to be slaves anymore,
if that's hilarious.
Yeah.
It was a medical condition.
They wrote about it in medical journals.
Wow.
Drapetomania that's hilarious.
Yeah.
You don't want to be free.
You're suffering from Drapetomania isn't credible.
You tweeted something today that I wanted to discuss with you.
Um,
is there such a thing as sex addiction?
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
Right.
That was a,
was that an article you were tweeting?
It's an article by Marty Klein who's a sex therapist for 30 some years.
What does all Marty,
I have to say,
Marty Says No.
Really?
No.
Marty says,
that's silly.
I could introduce him to some girl that I know.
He would change his mind.
Immediate.
Yeah,
but mean there's obviously psychological addictions.
Yeah.
What he's saying is,
is,
you know,
they're addictive personality types and it's,
it's not about the gambling or about the,
you know,
whatever it is.
You're addicted to the cell,
the jerking off in front of your computer or whatever.
It's about a certain personality or,
or different personality types that are highly susceptible to needing that sort
of stimulation over and over and over again.
And it could be anything that they could lock on the playing cards.
Sure,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing with human beings where again,
I think we're going back to the reward system that set us up when we were
hunters and gatherers for being successful.
And one of the things that got us be successful as persistence,
right?
This crazy laser beam persistence opposed to chasing that animal and focusing on
that animal and,
and being fixated on acquiring that animal.
But that can be like for aces,
I need fucking four races fucking four.
He says,
right?
It's like that same intensity.
It's sort of found this weird path where it's not being fulfilled by modern
everyday life of cubicle existence.
You know,
sitting there and checking your emails and waiting for the fucking clock to
strike five so he can run away and have your few hours of freedom because we're
trapped.
And that sort of a lifestyle.
All these reward systems are not being fulfilled and they're sort of manifesting
themselves in other ways.
How else can we get excitement?
Right?
We bet the house on Sunday,
but the house,
we got to fucking do something.
We need to fire this kiln up.
We need to do something to get ourselves excited.
Yeah.
Edward Abbey,
I think we,
there's a quote from Edward Abbey and our book where he talks about uh,
how sexuality is the only part of modern life that remains somewhat on
domesticated.
You know,
that we're like monkeys in a cage.
Like we just sit there jerking off cause we're,
there's nothing else to do,
you know?
Yeah.
That is something with people.
Like they'll start their day off by just finding something to jerk off to like
that's every day.
That's not a small amount of people.
That's like a lot of people,
like everyone between every man should 15 and 20 or so.
And at one point in time,
I mean there's so much access now.
It's like at one point in time it was difficult to find something to masturbate
too.
But now,
I mean,
if you have a computer,
I mean I have friends that won't,
they,
they'll have like a computer that doesn't have wifi or the Wifi Lil,
they'll break it on the computer just so that they make sure that they never go
online with it.
Like they'll,
you know,
the,
the tape take a chip out.
I'm not telling you if you have a spot in your house where you can't get Wifi,
go there and right there because otherwise your fucking computer,
it's right there.
That's the portal to pussy.
Didn't see it.
Anytime you want,
you just pressing a couple of and there's a girl blown a guy and like whoa.
It's like,
it's so prevalent.
It's no one ever thought that was coming.
You know,
in the back of the day when I was in high school and you had to get in magazines
and when VCR tapes came out it was a shocker.
But now it's on your phone.
Well,
there's a book called the erotic engine that argues that every advance in
communication technology,
you know,
back to the 18 hundreds has come about because of the desire to see and
broadcast pussy.
It's fascinating.
It's all about the
another weird sorta offshoot of the,
the constant technology progress,
you know?
Right.
Seems to,
it's leading us and then that's exactly the model we were talking about earlier.
It leads us in these steps always closer to what we think is going to give us
pleasure or satisfaction or something,
but in fact it may be leading us further and further away from the thumb.
True happiness.
Yeah.
Because it's so simple.
Well,
the idea is that we are evolving much like society's evolving and we need to
sort of physically and mentally and emotionally catch up with the amount of
progress that technology's making.
It fit into this new paradigm and find happiness within it that is achievable
and reachable.
And I,
and I think it is,
I think,
I certainly think that if you give people enough,
I think people inherently need,
especially men,
difficult tasks and their life they need to work.
Um,
I think work doesn't mean you know,
digging holes,
but it means putting your effort to something and finding a result in that.
And there's some sort of the,
that's how you become a man.
That's how you become a human.
That's how you learn how to sort of navigate your way through the world is by
trials and tribulations of trying to achieve things or to accomplish things or
to explore things.
Whether it's just your education,
you know,
delving into education and you'd become more,
more introspective because of that and more understanding of yourself and your,
your sort of fitting in in this strange world that we live in.
But if you don't have that,
if you don't,
if you don't have pursuits,
like that's where damage people come from.
That's where a lot of what's fucked up in this world comes from is that people
that aren't being led in a way that's going to develop them.
People that aren't being guided in some sort of a multistep process for
understanding and for,
for figuring out who you are and figuring out what's the best way to interact
with people.
What's the most harmonious way to live your life?
What's the way that makes you and the people that you come in contact with the
most happy and that's who you are,
just takes a long time to figure out how to become that person.
And we,
we live in this weird society now where everything is operating on this crazy
amount of momentum and you sorta just hop on the escalator and walk with it as
it's going and that's your life and you,
you very rarely have a chance to stop and calculate and formulate a game plan.
Yeah,
you're right.
So much of our behavior,
whether it's financial,
whether it's governmental or whether it's sexual,
much of it is based on like the silly notions and momentum,
the momentum of the people that set this whole system up way back don't even
exist.
Yeah.
And I see you again,
we get back to numbers cause I start to think it's I think less in terms of the
people who set it up and run it and more in terms of the internal logic of the
thing itself,
that the society is the organism and we live within the organism,
right?
Just like so many different bacteria and things live within us.
And you know,
you,
you think of yourself as an individual as do I,
but you know,
you've got the DNA from thousands of different organisms all necessary to your
life.
I,
I start to think we're inside.
It's almost like the,
you know,
when Romney said corporations are people,
they're not people,
but they're organisms,
they're alive.
They've got their own logic and their own needs and they don't give a shit about
us right there about making profit,
which requires destruction of natural resources.
There's nothing within a corporation that gives a damn that it's destroying the
planet.
Just like there's nothing within a pathogen that gives a damn that it's
destroying its host,
but it needs us in order to fulfill its destiny.
It needs our creativity in order to fulfill its destination.
I mean,
if you looked at technology as a,
as a life form itself,
you would,
I mean we don't think of when we think of parasites like the toxoplasma parasite
or any other sort of parasite that invades,
we think of them in organic terms.
But if you looked at what technology's doing to people,
it's like,
wow,
that's very parasitic.
And,
and us to it as well.
There's like this weird,
you could call it symbiosis,
but it's,
it's also parasitic because it's polluting everything while it's being created
and it's altering behavior.
You can make an argument that technology is bringing us closer together and
technology is bridging boundaries of consciousness and in spreading information
and an impossible.
But you can also make an argument that it's separating people from human
interaction.
Right?
And it's even,
it's like favoring the,
the ones and Zeros and,
and,
and numbers over actual humans
sial interactions.
That's,
that's what I'm saying,
that that the process favors the process is designed to satisfy the needs of the
macro organism,
not the microorganisms within it.
So human needs are not important in this process.
The need of a corporation or what's important,
you know,
so,
uh,
that's why I think we're,
we're less and less happy.
That's why I think we're civilized to death because we're,
we're moving further and further away from the things that make life satisfying.
I agree with you.
How do you feel about antidepressants?
I feel that they're like sorta like Drapetomania I think a lot of people are
quote unquote depressed because they're unhappy,
you know,
as opposed to organic,
Serotonin,
you know,
levels that are misaligned.
I'm talking about people,
I think people are fucking miserable.
Of course they're miserable,
their lives are meaningless.
They're,
you know,
the,
we mentioned,
you talk about the things that really make people happy.
Number one on the list is living in a community of people who love you.
Yeah.
That's the number one thing.
That's what you mentioned earlier,
you know,
with the lottery winners and saw on and as society becomes ever more fragmented
and you know,
more Americans are living alone right now as a percentage of the population than
ever before in our history.
You know,
that's demonstrates so many people are annoying.
That'd be alone.
Fucking watch.
Whatever you want to watch,
eat whatever you want.
Walk around naked.
Gives a fuck.
Leave me alone of that.
So it's,
you know,
you were talking about how we get caught on the wheel,
and there's no time to get off.
I that that's like the central insight of my life was when I felt that I felt
that momentum building and I took a summer off college.
I hitchhiked to Alaska and uh,
I got,
yeah,
I had,
I did it twice there and back twice.
Jesus Christ from New York to Alaska.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
What are the odds you picking up a rock and go,
hey man,
I'm going to Alaska.
And the guy's like,
Holy Shit.
Me Too.
Hopefully like each other.
We get along.
What's the longest,
longest ride you went on?
A,
I can't remember.
Probably when I can remember it.
It was from,
you know,
you take the ferry up,
the inside passage,
which is up the coast of Canada.
And then,
um,
the fairies don't go around a mainland Alaska as the water's just out of
control.
And there's,
I think it's called the Chugach mountains there.
So you to drive,
you have to go up the Alcan highway through the Yukon and then go across
horizontally to Fairbanks.
I think that's like 1200 kilometers or miles,
I don't even remember.
But that would be the longest ride.
A woman picked me and these two other guys up that I'd met and drove us all the
way.
It was like three days.
Wow.
What a crazy lady.
Great Lady.
And she was in a VW camper van with two little kids.
This was,
I think it was the second year.
So it was 84.
Wow.
How crazy was she?
She was wonderful in a VW camper.
Well,
she picked me up first,
um,
because I had been with these two guys and some guy picked us up down in the,
in the town,
I think it was Skagway in the town where the ferry docks [inaudible] we're
trying to hitch out and,
and some guy picked us up and drove us like 20 miles into the wilderness and
dropped us off and said,
watch out for the bears.
And he was just a dick.
So he just dropped you off,
like to be an asshole.
Just drove up.
Yeah.
He was a local guy and he was like,
yeah,
fuck you guys.
You know,
he was,
it was,
I don't remember,
this was long time ago obviously,
but he left us in the middle of nowhere and the only cars that came by were
coming off the ferry.
Right.
Cause there's no like road that went into this town.
So,
um,
so we were stuck there and,
and so it was like,
all right,
we set up our tents,
we had food and shit.
We were backpacking in Alaska,
we were self contained.
So we camped down next to this river and I had some acid we trip.
These two guys had never tripped before in their lives.
So you just like,
fuck it,
we can't get a ride.
Let's trip balls.
Well,
what else are we going to do?
We got to wait till Wednesday til the next ferry comes in.
Right.
So were there like three days?
So we stripped out the very interesting,
anyway,
these guys,
I had a lot of adventures with these guys.
I went to prison with one of them later that summer.
Jesus Christ man.
Yeah.
Nutty life.
But anyway,
so we decided nobody's going to pick up all three of us.
So they walked up the road and let me get the f the,
so we went out and waited for the cars and Jim's finally this woman's stops and,
and I knew my buddies were right up around the corner.
So as soon as I got in the van I was like,
Oh yeah,
you doing it was good.
Oh Man.
I've been hanging out with these really cool guys.
I met them and then we come around the corner.
I was like,
oh there they are.
And she just sort of looked at me and smiled and pulled over.
Okay.
So the three of us drove all the way to Fairbanks.
She sat in the back of the van with our kids,
played with the kids.
I had all these kids.
Two little kids.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
So crazy.
She was great.
What a chance.
She took really wow our kids and she was like,
oh,
what do you have a van?
Let me get in there.
A lady.
She was not.
Wow.
Well I'm glad it worked out and you guys weren't crazy.
You didn't wind know dismembering her family in the woods,
man.
I had my lucky hitchhiking shirt on.
You know that's a bold move to just go out there and hope to get a ride.
What's the longest you step like stood out there with your thumb out?
A few days.
I remember outside of white horse,
this was the year before I was with my friend Mike.
We're outside of Whitehorse.
We were there like two,
two nights at least.
We slept by the highway and then weird.
He's,
I swear this is true to the next day we get up,
we walked up the highway a little bit,
you know,
got our tents set up and everything,
back in her backpack and a walk up the highway a little bit.
And this is like Tundra,
right?
There's,
I don't know if you've been to this part of the world,
Yukon,
it's just like flat empty.
It's Arctic desert essentially.
You know,
there's scrub whatever and woke up a little bit and we find on the side of the
road of book that had been there for God knows how long the pages were just like
really tightly curled back from the spine,
you know,
was like a,
some sort of bizarre shellfish or something.
And we sort of killed it down and it was a bible.
Whoa.
So we lit,
we lit it on fire and we started dancing around this Bible right here.
We're like,
you know,
just nuts,
right?
And this truck comes by this pickup truck and s and at first we were like,
you know,
oh they,
some of them just got here and yeah,
it's God,
right?
They back up to us and it's these three guys.
It's like a dude in his 50s from New Mexico or something and he's crazy ass
nephew who was like 23 and his nephews friend and they were just like,
yeah,
who like real,
real Bozo dudes.
Like they were pissed off that everything was more expensive in Canada.
They didn't understand the money thing,
you know that it was different dollars.
They were pissed off that the Canadians wouldn't let them bring their guns
through Canada.
There's all this stuff.
They picked us up anyway,
put us in the back,
stopped when we crossed back into Alaska and they got out and kiss the ground to
be back in America.
So they picked us up when we burned the Bible.
Wow.
He channeled them.
I guess he channeled like one of the best examples of weirdness in America.
Like this super patriotic retards.
Exactly.
That's fascinating.
Toting.
Yeah.
That was your vehicle to get over.
They got us out.
What a strange lifestyle it is to just fucking hitchhike play places and not
exactly know who's going to take you or what's going to happen.
And I like hunting,
gathering,
you know,
not really.
It's kind of like putting yourself in a metal box with a psycho.
You don't,
you know,
you can take a wild guess and you could be okay.
You know,
you might,
I met some Psychos,
a lot of Psychos,
a lot of like homosexual guys and a lot of Jesus freaks.
Like what happened?
What's the craziest thing that happened while I checking homosexuals first and
was getting life coach?
Well that the homeless,
I got to say that homosexuals
were were fine.
They were,
they were,
you know,
they were lonely,
they were lonely guys and they were hoping and they were hoping and I guess a
lot of dudes that,
you know,
there's like a sort of a system,
but like,
Hey,
I'm not gay,
you know?
And then at that time my best friend was gay and I'm certainly comfortable.
Right.
Did you bring your best friend over to blown for the ride?
Yeah,
that'd be what I'd move.
Actually,
he came to Alaska later that summer,
but he flew up.
He was,
he was a professor in the school.
We shouldn't have to prostitute himself either,
just for a ride.
I mean,
either going to give him a ride or not blow the pilot,
get a flight out of it anyway,
just to ride.
Really.
It's not,
but I'll tell you,
one of the more memorable hitchhiking things was I was
coming back and I was coming from Montreal down to New York.
I had friends I wanted to see in New York,
so I was coming down that,
that highway that goes down through the Adirondack mountains,
you know,
very desolate,
kinda empty country.
And I always had a knife in my right boot.
Um,
when I was hitchhiking,
just like you say,
things can get really weird.
And I figured,
well,
you know,
at least I've got a knife and like stop the fucking car.
Right,
right.
Um,
but it's under my jeans and I had these army boots and I always had it in the
boot under my jeans.
So I'm,
I'm out there and,
uh,
this guy pulls over for me and he's like,
crew cut in military know ex military looking dude,
you know,
a real fit,
tattoos,
the whole thing.
And he's like,
uh,
yeah,
so where are you from?
What he'd done?
And,
and uh,
and,
and within two minutes of the conversation,
he says,
so you like knives?
And he sort of says it in that like he's not asking,
he's noting and I said,
yeah,
I like,
and I was,
I guess.
And he said,
yeah,
I noticed you've got one under your boot.
They're on the right.
And I was like,
oh Jeez.
And I'm sitting in the car,
how's he noticed I've got a knife in my boot,
like on the side of the car?
He said,
yeah,
I noticed when I picked you up.
He said,
I like nice too.
And he reaches into his belt buckle and goes and pulls out a knife that was in
his belt buckle and now that knife is like right in front of my face.
And I'm like,
fuck man,
this could be really bad,
you know,
and I'm looking at it and I said,
this is really nice knife.
He said,
yeah.
And like,
like he let me take the knife and hold it and like,
oh yeah.
Wow,
that's cool.
That's in your buckle,
Huh?
Like yeah,
and I've got another one here and he pulls out another night.
By now I'm like,
he's not going to kill me.
He's just showing me is nice.
The guy was a prison guard at Attica.
Whoa.
He drove me all the way to New York.
He was a prison guard and the thing was like,
he's a trained,
he's trained to notice shit like a knife under your right.
Right.
They'll see the bulge.
That made such an impression on me because at that point I,
I stopped carrying a knife first of all because like,
because those dudes are pros and I'm an amateur.
Last thing I want to do is escalate the situation and it just really made this
like,
you know,
I think I'm getting away with something and now there are people,
people who know what to look for,
they're always one step ahead of you.
It's tough like getting into,
I don't know if you've ever been interrogated by police.
It's,
it's hard because they,
they've done it a thousand times.
Yeah.
I've got a question.
Wants,
does that interrogated?
Yeah,
same thing.
I got a question once cause I knew a dude who knew a dude who killed somebody.
It was a weird conversation because I had a conversation on the phone with them
and then they,
the cops wanted to ask me.
But what I knew because they were listening to his phone calls,
I was like,
that was kinda interesting too.
I was like Whoa.
I think tapped his fucking phone.
That's Kinda crazy.
Wow.
Yeah.
Luckily I didn't know shit but it was a weird sort of a situation like drink
what is,
is it legal to know the guy might've killed somebody.
It's supposed to go right to the cops with that.
Like if you don't know whether or not someone's full of shit or not,
right.
What are you supposed to do there?
Yeah.
I think you're safe.
But that insight that you get caught up in this momentum.
What happened that that year in Alaska that first year was I,
my entire life plan changed cause I was like on the track to go to Grad school
right away.
Go to,
I knew a guy who was at Oxford who had me all set up to go to Oxford,
do a phd in literature,
which is what I was studying at that point.
And you know,
just go right in and be a professor at teaching literature,
you know,
some college by the time I was 30 with tenure and all set up and you know,
and I went up to Alaska and I met all these people who blew my mind too,
were really kind and generous and smart and deep people who weren't
intellectuals,
right,
who had no idea who needs your was or whatever.
And my friends back in,
you know,
my sort of high Iq friends would have scoffed at these people,
but in fact they were happier.
They had a better life than my miserable,
arrogant professor friends.
And it really made me think about where I was going in life.
And I said,
okay,
so here's what I'm going to do until I'm 30 I'm not going to get on that wheel.
I'm not going to go to Grad school.
I'm not going to get married.
I'm not going to have a career.
I'm just going to float around the world.
Do Crazy Shit.
Meet crazy people.
Think about what I want to do with my life.
But don't start till after 32.
Give yourself an actual number just to say at least till 30.
Like no commitment.
Your commitment is to not make a commitment.
And so your third,
there's those money.
There's a lot of shows that are on the air.
Uh,
lately.
about Alaska.
There's a right,
the subsistence shows,
whether it's subsistence shows his families just survive in Alaska and then they
show how many different villages,
um,
rely completely on nature.
Right.
I'm obsessed with these shows.
It's so fascinating to me that there so compelling this chase of food,
you know,
whether it's,
they're growing some food there,
they're collecting salmon out of the river there.
They're shooting animals and cutting them up and freezing them and they're just,
everyone just goes nuts for four months.
Stockpiles all the food and then weights and then the whole thing freezes for
eight months.
And it's really weird.
A lot of backgammon.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck they do,
but essentially they barely shower and cleaned themselves for eight months.
They were talking about clothes about like during the winter,
like you barely wash her clothes cause you can't,
things just freeze instantly.
It's 40 below zero.
How do you keep clothes wet?
You know,
what do you do?
You go out and put them out because they hang their clothes sort of outside to
dry.
Good luck with that step outside.
It's frozen instantly.
There's a guy who lives in Alaska and he's a Q maker and uh,
he was on the phone with a friend of his and uh,
he took a bucket of hot water and it was so cold that he took a bucket of on the
phone with him.
He said,
well,
I'm watching,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna do this for you.
I'll throw the water.
This is how cold it is.
He throws the hot water up in the air before it hits the ground.
It's frozen.
It was 90,
below zero or something.
Fucking crazy.
See if I,
if I have to be subsistence,
I don't want to do it there.
Woo.
But it's so glorious.
Like when you see these people that are,
you know,
hunting Caribou or a hunting black bear and you see the landscape that they're
traveling on and how few people there are one of them.
Was this a family that's related to the singer jewel?
Do you know the singer jewel?
It,
her family's Iceland?
No.
Well,
our family,
um,
I think,
I think the family is originally from like Sweden or some shit.
And then when Hitler was storming Europe,
they decided to move to Alaska and start this subsistence living and singer
jewel comes from this family.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
And um,
I'm pretty sure,
I hope it's not bullshit.
Wow.
But uh,
to,
to watch the show with this family's like living on the same piece of land that
their grandfather got in like the 1940s.
It's amazing stuff.
Really,
really interesting stuff.
You know,
they're just out there.
They have cattle and then the entire year is a collection run.
It's just run around,
collect,
hey,
run around and collect animals,
freeze them,
collect fish.
And they're,
they have nights where they don't have anything to eat.
And then they have to get up in the morning and go trap rabbits.
And you know,
it's like,
whoa.
Like that is a nutty fucking wait to live man.
But yeah.
Meanwhile,
how much different is it than someone living check to check,
you know,
and being on the subway with a bunch of other crazy assholes or watching someone
get pushed in front of the car,
you know,
the weirdness that we have to deal with in modern society.
Yeah.
Well the,
the fact is the stress level's much lower.
I suppose.
Skate we were talking about earlier,
one of his big points he makes about stress,
he wrote a book called why zebras don't get ulcers,
which is a pretty good book.
Um,
but he makes this big distinction between chronic stress and acute stress.
Right.
And we're evolved to deal with acute stress.
Like,
you know,
sleep,
not,
not eating one night,
you know,
there's no food.
So you go out the next day and you deal with that.
What we're not evolved to deal with is chronic stress.
You know,
sitting in traffic every day,
you know,
waking up to an alarm clock every morning,
the,
all of this on the subway every day or whatever it is,
you know,
that's,
we're not evolved to deal with that.
That's what wipes the sound.
It makes us crazy cancer and all kinds of other shit.
The,
um,
the kind of stress that we deal with on a regular basis of the stress of not
wanting to do something,
but having to do it all day and being not satisfying whatsoever.
Right.
The process,
what you were talking about earlier,
the process of gathering food,
creating food,
growing food,
um,
and,
and catching fish or whatever is very satisfying.
Right?
It's like,
it feels great.
Well,
that's what we do for vacation,
right?
It's like,
that's how they live.
We go fishing,
we go hunting,
you know,
go hiking in the mountains.
That's what they're doing day to day.
Yeah,
of course they're fucking happy.
You know,
there were these people on Darwin's boat.
Do you know about the,
I think I talked about,
we talked to one in sex at dawn.
Um,
uh,
it was Jimmy,
Jimmy York,
and there were three adolescent,
a few gins,
Indians that,
that the captain of the Beagle had picked up on an earlier voyage.
These kids and they,
he took them back to England so they could be educated in England and see the
glory of the English life and proper
living properly and all that.
And then on the,
on the,
the voyage Darwin was on,
they were taking them back to Tierra del Fuego where they were going to teach
their people like how to come out of the woods and live properly and all that.
And so Darwin knew these people really well and by the time they got there,
they built them a cabin.
They made a garden,
they got them all set up and they left them there and said,
okay,
we'll be back in three months.
They took off and they were mapping the coast of South America.
They came back three months later,
the cabin was abandoned,
the garden was completely grown over and nobody was there.
So they went looking for them,
put out word,
they wanted to see them.
And finally one of them came back and went out on the boat to have dinner with
Darwin and the captain and they were like,
what's,
you know what happened?
Wait,
will you wait?
What did you do?
What's going on?
And he's like,
man,
he's like,
he said,
why should I farm?
There are plenty birdies.
Plenty.
Fishies it's like forget that farming shit.
You know,
like all everything we taught you,
you abandon it in a couple of months to go back and live in the mountains.
You know,
something that looks miserable to the British.
Right.
But for the people who had experienced both sides,
they were like,
fuck that man wearing these silly uncomfortable shoes and clothes and digging in
the dirt.
There are plenty of fish and birds and stuff to eat.
Yeah.
When you see farmers you don't think like happy good time singing around the
campfire,
stoic existence,
right.
Rising in the morning and milking like washing the plows and it looks like
death.
Whereas like hunting and gathering is kind of fun.
Yeah.
It's inherently enjoyable.
But why?
Because that's how we evolve.
Gardening is fun.
Gardening is you got to find like there's a,
there's like a middle ground between gardening and being a farmer and there's
something about having domesticated animals that's pretty nice too.
Short chickens and you know,
they have eggs every morning and the super fresh.
And if you've never had like fresh eggs,
the really is a difference in the way they taste like an egg that comes right
out of a chicken.
You eat it that day.
They,
that's a,
it's very delicious.
If you could have chickens,
that'd be any,
kill those bitches and eat them too.
If the shit hits the fan until you what?
[inaudible] my wife was raised in Mozambique and she used to go out in the
summers to her grandmother's farm,
which is like rural Mozambique is rural,
right.
And they had to,
they had a dog that was eaten by a tiger and shit,
you know,
seriously row.
So,
so one day Cassie and I are in Amsterdamse beautiful spring day by a canal and
these ducks are paddling by,
it's just like,
you know,
it's a for me or painting or something.
And Cassie's looking at the ducks really intently.
And I said,
what are you thinking?
She said,
oh,
I was just thinking how great it would be to grab that duck in the front and
break its neck and gut it and pluck it and stuff it with garlic and peppers and
you know,
like she had this whole thing like the way her grandmother used to do,
tell ya if the income she's,
she's in charge of food.
No problem.
It's funny how people eat meat,
but yet look at that in a very,
uh,
you know,
as being a distasteful thing to think as being,
yeah,
I mean I,
I'm ashamed,
but it's true.
It would be hard for me to kill.
Do you think that these ideas,
have you ever considered that this is a part of what it is,
sort of the natural progression from the,
the,
the ape from the ape that lives in the forest to being this sort of an
enlightened aware thing with massive access to information that somewhere along
the line we must separate ourselves from the hunter gatherer instincts and
reward systems.
And one of the ways to do that is with antidepressants and supermarkets and that
like is a slow push away and that we have to fulfill these weird needs and other
ways and that sort of facilitates the great machine.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I think it is essentially a struggle between the interests of the machine and
the interest of the organisms that live within it.
And so I what I'm hoping I'll,
although I'm not that hopeful,
but I'm,
I'm hoping that at some point our intelligence,
uh,
allows us to consciously choose
our own interests over the interests of the machine.
Right?
I mean,
it's what you were talking about earlier,
developing,
uh,
sources of energy that don't destroy the planet.
You know,
developing ways to interact that is respectful of our individuality and,
and,
you know,
developing,
um,
sexual mores that allow people to get pleasure in their lives.
I mean,
I was talking to a friend the other night who's gone through a crisis and,
um,
okay.
He said,
you know,
it was,
it was a Christmas Eve,
right?
So everyone's with their families.
All his friends were sorta on out of touch.
He,
he really didn't have anybody to hang out with and he was going through a really
hard time with a family member and stuff.
He ended up in a strip club paying a woman $300 to hold him.
Well,
right.
That's the kind of world we're in.
Okay.
You know,
it's people are touched,
starved babies or touch star.
A lot of my will tell you it's not even about the massage,
it's about being touched.
Right?
So I think at some point I'm,
we have to recognize like,
wait a minute,
this is going in one direction.
But the things that actually make us happy are not out there.
They're not in that direction.
And the only way we can slow it down or stop it or even change direction,
I think is learning to have far fewer people on the planet.
Because the more people there are,
the more that wheel gets fueled and spins faster and faster.
And the only way to slow it down is far fewer people,
especially in other countries.
I mean the United States is probably the best country in the world,
so we can keep our numbers very high.
So keep having as many kids as you like,
but [inaudible] you Mexican immigrants.
Yeah.
Um,
that's a weird,
it's a weird thing to say to people that people get very defensive when you talk
about reducing the number of people on the planet.
I'm not saying to kill anybody,
but there's no other way to do it.
They can't live if they can't live someone's,
we're all done.
We're all going to die.
Let him die.
You know,
attrition.
We can let it go with attrition,
but w what,
what's going on with health and nutrition and science and Madison,
it's like prolonging lifespans and stretching people out.
Like that's an interesting,
what if it becomes infinite?
I mean there,
there's,
there's talk it especially if you're in the Kurzweil camp setting,
I'd be able to extend lifespan.
Like Aubrey de Grey believes that within the next hundred years are going to be
able to be a thousand years old.
You have a C.
I think a lot of that thinking is based on faulty assumptions.
Maybe not him in particular,
but there's a section in sex at dawn where we talk about the longevity lie,
you know,
which is that most people think that human beings in prehistory,
these ancestors we've been talking about only,
you know,
live to 35 or so.
Somebody is 30 was an old person.
Well Noah was 600.
He was an exception.
We know he was exceptional.
Um,
so,
so a lot of people are saying,
well,
hey,
we've doubled the human lifespan.
Why can't we continued it?
But it hasn't doubled.
Human lifespan is 60,
70,
75 years.
Even in the wild.
I rarely 75 years,
but it,
you know,
we're not going to,
there's no evidence that the human lifespan has doubled ever.
So this thinking that we can just keep,
you know,
increasing it isn't going to work.
What are you sending me man?
Sending me texts?
It was the lamp was fairly,
oh,
I thought you were trying to tell me something and a secret message.
Yeah,
me too.
Like,
get rid of this guest.
How
dare you.
This is fascinating stuff,
man.
Um,
do you think it is also possible that,
as you know,
I would not like to go back to being a monkey?
I would not like to go back to picking cow patties up and looking for bugs to
eat.
Right.
We have progressed to the point where we are now living in a civilized,
civilized society,
which I enjoy.
I enjoy the Internet.
I enjoy television and restaurants.
I enjoy cars.
I enjoy going to the movies.
I enjoy a lot of the aspects I so I don't necessarily buy the idea that no one
is happy and that's impossible to be happy in this environment.
Is it possible that it's just simply a matter of catch up and that we all must
sort of morph and move on with the times?
Just as we have in going from being monkeys with no houses to people with
houses,
two guys with cars,
right.
I mean that this is just a natural part of the progression of the universe and
then the idea of hanging onto the past,
this nostalgia for the simpler times,
it's really kind of silly.
Right?
And that even our notions about sexuality or notions of,
uh,
communication and privacy,
all those are sort of ancient and they're,
they're really,
there are only applicable to a world where the internet doesn't exist.
And as that this internet gets stronger and stronger and more and more
pervasive,
which is obviously doing,
it's going to eventually get to some point where it's ridiculous to think that
you could ever like the people in the taiga.
I hear you man.
But,
but that argument's very similar to saying,
um,
look,
you know,
the,
the sort of holistic,
the food you get at whole foods,
people can't afford that.
And a lot of it's bullshit anyway.
Even if it's labeled organic or whatever free range,
it's still the DA,
Da,
da.
So,
you know,
we should all just deal with it and eat it Mcdonald's,
because that's where we're going.
Maybe there's a practical truth to that,
but the problem is it just like the body,
if you don't give the body the exercise patterns,
the sleep,
the,
the nutritional content and so on,
the fiber and all that,
it evolved to want whatever you think about whatever.
However your your identity or your sense of life has adapted,
your body still won't respond to it correctly.
Right.
You'll still get sick and die from it.
So there's a level I,
you know,
I have a friend who's a cardiologist who says to me,
I don't feel stress.
Right?
I don't feel it.
I was like,
dude,
you feel it.
Even if you don't think you feel that,
you still feel it and you're,
you're,
I mean,
and I'm arguing about stress with a cardiologist,
which isn't a good thing to do,
but he's,
you know,
we asked too,
he's human.
That's the point.
You know,
I think even traffic is tress.
Exactly.
Well and sticking a catheter up somebodies,
you know,
artery to fuck around with their heart,
it's gotta be stressful,
you know,
intensity and that intensity is stressful.
You know,
it's like people,
even great things.
The idea of stress is always sort of,
it has a negative connotation,
but it's intensity.
It's like whether anything you,
if you're playing a video game with stressful,
I mean,
it's your,
your system is being taxed.
You know,
you're looking at all these graphics,
you're moving around.
That is trust fall.
It's not that negative.
Right.
You know,
you're red lining shit,
you know?
Yeah.
Your system is not necessarily set up.
So I mean,
to answer your question,
I think that's a legitimate argument for sure and in a legitimate critique of
all this sort of thinking.
But I do think that there's a part of the human organism that,
that can't adapt anywhere near as fast as society's changing.
So it'll always be stuck in the pleistocene and the only way to deal with it has
to understand what that environment was like and try to adapt your life in
important ways to bring it into,
into sync with that way of life.
I completely
agree.
And I don't mean to suggest in any way that people shouldn't sort of manage
their consciousness in a more valuable way or in a more,
a more applicable way.
You know what I'm saying is that I,
when I look at the progression of the,
the ape like creatures that we must have been at one point in time to what we
are today.
I mean,
what is it going to be like a thousand years from now,
a hundred thousand years,
for a million years from now,
we're obviously going to be something completely different.
We're going to be moot if we exist in the same physical form.
It's going to be very odd.
It's gonna.
It's going to be something that's going to happen.
And this really seems to be like a matter of trying to enjoy this thing that
you're trapped in this,
this dimension and you're trapped in.
And one of the ways inherently that's the,
I think it's very important is to appreciate the physical.
And because the,
especially with,
um,
people,
I don't want to say intellectuals,
but people that fancy themselves,
intellectuals more than true intellectuals cause a true intellectual,
we'll probably check taking into account all the different variables and,
and understand that the body is of your meat vehicle has to be tended to in the
proper way in order for you to get the right feelings from it.
And it part of your negative feelings with your mind.
It's got to be connected to this thing that's carrying you around.
Right?
Um,
but I think that concentrating on that,
it's thought as being a base thing,
like a not important a,
uh,
you know,
it's out just so rudimentary.
It's so unnecessary.
It's so,
so a bish you know,
we don't really need to concentrate on that,
but we really do sexually as far as the,
the stress that you get from everyday life of input.
I'm a big believer in the sensory deprivation tank.
We have one in my basement and uh,
I've,
I've been using them for years.
And one of the best things about the sensory deprivation tank is that it offers
you this environment where nothing's coming at you and like literally nothing,
no sensory input at all.
And it's so hard to achieve that anywhere else in the world.
Well,
when you're in that tank,
there's just nothing.
You're floating through space and you,
you,
nothing's coming at you.
And it's such a recharge,
so much better for me than sitting in front of the television for an hour or
sitting in a couch,
which you have the nice things to do to relax.
It's nice to sit back and just veg out for a little bit.
But that environment is something that not enough people experience the
environment of the isolation tank and John Lilly?
No,
no.
He was gone before I found out about it all.
I think he died,
I don't know when he died actually,
but
late seventies maybe.
Yeah,
I friends family knew him.
Oh yeah.
Fascinating dude.
Yeah.
Stan,
you should meet Stanley sometimes.
Stanley knew everybody.
Stanley was this,
my professor in Grad School and uh,
we had breakfast together one day when I first started and a w and then later I
got a note saying,
you know,
Dr Kripner would like to meet you,
come to his office,
whatever.
I go talk to him and he's just sweet old guy.
And he says,
listen,
you know,
your life sounds pretty a on an anchor.
Do you know you've got a lot of freedom in your life.
I'm going to Brazil in two months.
Would you like to go with me?
All expenses paid.
You know,
the people who are inviting me to Brazil will pay for my assistant to go,
whatever.
It's like,
fuck yeah,
let's go.
So I went to Brazil with Stanley and then how long?
That was like 10 days or something.
Wow.
And Out Stanley is one of the world's most renowned experts in things like
telepathy on altered states of consciousness and shamanism,
dream interpretation,
all this kind of Freaky d.
What's his first name?
Stanley Kripner.
Two.
Let's get them.
Can we get them?
Oh,
he's super cool.
No,
you can gal.
I'll have him come down yet.
He's 80.
He just turned 80.
We were at his birthday party in Berkeley a couple of weeks ago.
Wow.
Uh,
Daniel Ellsberg was there.
Stan Groff.
I mean,
Stanley tripped with Timothy leary.
He knew,
he knew Alan Watts.
You know this whole,
like intellectual 60 seventies hippy intellectual scene.
Stanley was the young guy.
He was the like in house psychologist for the grateful dead for years.
Hung out with on an inhouse psychologist.
He was just,
he was,
you know what he was,
he was what you were talking about earlier where like the prominent people just
have a smart guy hang around.
That's what Stanley was the smart guy who's smart with the grateful dead.
That's a,
that's a brilliant move.
Yeah.
Have a dude like that around with you.
When you went to those,
Brian,
we need to get a super smart dude come around with us.
Joey Diaz
for you.
Joey Diaz represents the oracle.
He's the impossible knowledge that can never be achieved.
Is it about that be a daddy today?
I think that's an easy today.
Tonight.
Tonight I'm thinking to induce.
Wow.
He tweeted something today about like,
this is his last day of having no responsibilities.
There's wow.
Crazy.
So,
um,
this,
this book
and the,
the information that you,
you,
you put out from it,
how has it been received?
Have you,
um,
I mean it's obviously a very successful book,
but have,
what kind of criticism have you,
uh,
had to encounter with,
it's been interesting that the,
um,
I would say the response has been 95% positive,
which is not at all what we expected.
We were expecting 50,
50 at best.
Um,
the negative criticism has been,
yeah,
I'm going to sound like an asshole saying this,
but I think most of it has been pretty emotional.
It hasn't been a arguing the intellectual points made in the book.
It's been just sort of freaking out.
Um,
like one of the first reviews was,
uh,
by,
an economist named Megan mcardle,
one of the first negative reviews.
Uh,
she reviewed it and her blog and she just said,
like,
she just,
she,
first of all it said it was written really poorly and blah,
blah,
blah.
But then she said,
um,
human beings are not like,
Bonobos,
you know how I know this?
And then in bold because we're not like Benobos that was her argument.
That's a silly argument.
That's a chick who's worried that her pussy is not that valuable.
Yeah.
She had just recently been married.
Actually someone told me later,
yeah,
probably was like totally clinging to the idea
monogamy,
but you know,
you're not discounting the idea of a happy monogamous life in that book at all.
What you're doing is just talking about the real history of human beings.
And,
um,
I didn't find it.
I was,
I thought it was going because I had heard the resistance about it.
I thought it was going to be much more controversial than it was.
But it,
I mean,
not,
not really much more,
but I thought it was possible based on the reactions that I had heard from
people.
But I thought it was,
you know,
pretty factual.
Well,
and we're not arguing,
and this is a point I have to make an in interviews all the time and we're not
arguing that there's anything wrong with monogamy.
Just like we're not arguing that there's anything wrong with vegetarianism,
right?
You can choose to be a vegetarian and it can be smart and healthy and ethical
and you know,
very good decision,
but don't expect it to come naturally to you.
Just because you've chosen to be a vegetarian doesn't mean bacon suddenly
doesn't smell good anymore.
Right?
So,
you know,
understand you're going to have challenges if you take that path.
It's an uphill path.
And the reason it's an uphill path is because your ancestors lived like this,
you know?
So to me there's no advice implicit in that and we,
we got a lot of pressure actually from publishers to make it,
uh,
like a self help kind of book real.
Oh yeah.
They were really into that.
Well that's something we were talking about before we started recording about
dealing with people and dealing with publishers.
Anybody who wants to sort of like direct your vision,
right.
Of what,
you know,
ultimately your book is your art.
I mean this is your,
your take on your work on this particular subject.
But yeah,
someone will come along and say,
you know what,
it'd be more entertaining if you decided to make it a game show.
It's sex at dawn,
the game show.
If someone approached us recently,
you wanted to make,
uh,
an illustrated kids version.
Whoa,
Jack.
Yeah.
That's a channel that I want to leave origins out of that.
How do you,
how do you do cartoon orgies?
Like Sponge Bob Square pants type dudes?
What do you,
sorry.
No,
please.
I was just gonna say other reactions,
like one woman,
uh,
didn't believe Kasota really exists that my publisher and I can spire to make up
a female co author to obscure the male privileged Phallocentric,
you know,
perspective.
Oh,
that's funny.
So that's Q,
that sort of thing.
Um,
we haven't gotten any response at all from like the Christian.
Right.
You know,
who I was hoping we'd get really offended and freak out and loud voices,
but there hasn't been a peep out of them.
There's a bit of intellectual bigotry involved in anything.
Anything masculine like a,
anything that is a masculine trait or a masculine masculine wants or needs or
behavior patterns.
It's almost a rife for criticism.
Like no right away.
Like automatically intellectually dismissed,
you know,
whether it's aggression or sexual needs or anything like that.
Automatically intellectually dismissed.
You know,
Neil Strauss for the name?
Uh,
he was,
he,
he wrote a book called the game.
Oh yes.
Okay.
That's right.
I got bar.
It is thing.
I interviewed him on my podcast and I said to him like,
you,
what do you say to people who say you're just teaching losers?
How to manipulate women,
you know?
And he was like,
yeah,
interesting.
You know,
how much time do women spend learning how to manipulate men?
Right?
But I some do but some don't.
You know,
some,
some pride themselves and just being real.
But yeah.
But the point is women are much better at at dealing with relationship,
let's say relationship skills,
right?
You've got the cosmetics industry,
you've got all this cosmetic surgery,
you've got to get of the hairstyles and the fashion.
That's all about attracting male attention.
Right,
right.
And rolling male attention.
I'm not saying women are using it to hurt men necessarily,
but I'm saying there is a huge industry around helping women deal with men and
he was saying like the first time you start talking about helping men deal with
women,
it gets dismissed.
And the way you were saying
it's true,
but in my opinion what he's doing is like horse shit.
Yeah.
It's a temporary fix.
Like really what you need to do is be a bad motherfucker.
Be figure out a way to be a real man,
you know,
be a real man.
I always say,
and this is a corny way of saying it,
but it really works be the hero in your own story.
If you were living a movie and you're,
you're the,
the,
the guy that everybody admires and he woke up and this is his situation,
how would he handle it?
How would you handle each individual moment that you encounter in your life?
Well,
if you're the guy that you would look up to,
how would you deal with it?
Just did.
There you go.
That's what I do.
That shit.
Yeah,
but see not everyone can do that.
You say that,
but I'm not sure if that's true.
I think that limiting sort of thinking is very dangerous because who are you?
Who am I?
Am I the type of person that can do it or am I the type of person that fails?
And is there a difference between the two and is the difference between the two
focus and intensity belief?
What is it?
Is it genetics?
Is it circumstantial?
What is it?
I'm not exactly sure.
So to say that not everybody can do that.
I think everybody can do it.
I think everybody could do their own.
But don't you think it's a mix of all those things?
Yes.
And some of those things are out of our control.
You know?
I mean,
I,
I feel very privileged.
I grew up,
I had unconditional love from my parents.
They had enough money that I knew if I ever really got into trouble,
they could bail me out and they would,
they'd sell their house,
they'd do whatever to come save me,
you know,
when I overdosed or wrecked a motorcycle and Thailand or some stupid shit.
So I felt free to do things that I think a lot of kids don't feel,
you know,
hey,
one of your parents is dead.
There's no money.
You're,
you don't have the chance to say,
Hey,
fuck it,
I'm going to Hitchhike to Alaska.
And I wrote a,
an essay in psychology today while ago.
I was reminded,
remember when the Sikhs got shot recently in Wisconsin or wherever it was.
And I was thinking about the first time I'd ever met a Sikh.
It was,
I'd been working in New York and the diamond district,
which is a whole crazy period of my life.
But I quit that job and flew to Nutaliay one way ticket to new Dell.
I wanted to go see the world,
right.
So I had about $15,000 in cash in my money belt because someone had told me that
you got a better exchange on cash,
hundred dollar bills then you did with traveler's checks.
So I had all this cash,
right?
I was going to go travel until the cash ran out.
I figured two,
three years,
it was my plan.
So I land in New Delhi and I go,
I get this,
a little room and old Deli near the train station and night I would sleep with
my money belt under the pillow because someone had told him like,
the locks on the doors are ridiculous.
And somebody told me like,
watch out.
People come in at night.
You gotta be really careful.
So I hid my money belt under,
under my pillow and uh,
I got this ticket to go to cashmere.
Very early trained.
It was like a 40 hour train or something to cashmere and it left at 6:00 AM or
something.
So the night before I packed up my backpack,
got everything ready.
So in the morning all I did do is wake up,
brush my teeth and go,
right.
So I did,
I'm sitting in the train station waiting,
having a Chai.
It's,
you know,
almost five 30 or something.
The Sun's coming up,
it's already really hot and this bead of sweat rolls down my spine and I go to
touch it.
Where's my money belt?
I left it under the pillow.
Oh,
this is like five days into my adventure.
Chris is going to go see the world,
you know intrepid traveler,
dude,
all my money is in this fucking guest house near the trains.
So I run with my backpack and run back to this thing.
Go Up,
there's the seek.
The owner is awake by this point and he's like,
what are you doing?
Oh do I just ran past them up to the door,
banging on the door.
People inside speaking Hindi.
They won't open the door.
I don't know what the fuck.
I go down to the front desk and he's like,
well,
hey,
what's happening with you?
I said,
I left something in my room.
He said,
what did you leave?
I said,
some papers,
I need some,
some papers.
I left there.
He said,
what kind of papers and my Indian accent.
So,
um,
I,
and I felt like my passport.
All right,
look my passport.
He said,
oh my God,
you left your passport in the room.
Anything else?
And he's looking at me like there's this look like he's not unfriendly,
this guy,
but he's not stupid.
And he's looking at me a lot in a way that,
and I feel like I'm being tested in a way.
Yes.
And when I've come to those moments in life,
which I have several times,
my instinct is just tell the fucking truth.
Right?
Just naked,
you know,
like naked.
Don't try to play,
you know,
it's like what I was saying about the knife and the boot.
It's like,
Eh,
you're better off undefended in a way.
And I said,
I left all my money there.
He said,
all your money,
how much money?
I said about $15,000
$15,000 so you have a $15,000 he reaches under the table,
hands me my money,
but oh my God,
I look at it and I don't count the money,
but there's a stack of hundreds in it.
Did you give him one eye?
He said,
well,
while I'm looking at it,
he said,
the boy who cleans your room found this.
He makes about $7 in a month.
Kidneys.
A new job.
Yeah.
So I took a couple of hundreds out and I handed them to him.
I said,
please give them to him,
to the boy and to thank you.
And he said,
no,
you'll offend him.
You can't do that.
Wow.
So I said,
well,
what can I do?
He said,
uh,
you know,
give me,
I don't know what it was.
Five,
10 bucks or something and I'll have a party to honor him among all of the
employees.
Wow.
He says,
no,
you go get your train and be careful.
Be careful with your money.
And so I think back on that guy.
I think that guy saved my life because I look at myself now as bad.
I'm this adventurous guy.
I went all over the world,
I've done this,
I've done that.
And I always came out of it.
Okay.
And I've done,
that guy could have put me on a completely different track where I'd be calling
my parents,
you know,
collect a week after leaving the country to get,
uh,
you know,
borrow money for a flight back to their basement.
That would have been a different life.
So I guess what I'm saying to you is not everyone's lucky.
Yes and no,
because I say you're just basing your,
the whole chain of events on what would have happened if you didn't have that
money.
If you lost that money,
you could have gone on an equal adventure,
if not greater.
It could have been more spiritually fulfilling because people actually helped
you and you realize money's not important.
You know,
I can barter with my work and who knows?
And you know,
your version of why you were willing to take chances in your life is based on a
version of having a safety net.
My version is the total opposite.
I don't even know my father and my mother had me when she was young.
She worked all the time.
No one was ever home.
And I was,
I was raised by wolves.
So I essentially figured my own path or life and rejected the normal notions of
what you should and shouldn't do because I saw these people were miserable and I
didn't want to be like them.
And so I think that water seeks its own level and I think that curiosity and a a
person and you know,
a desire to see things and experience things,
it sort of a,
it's a part of being a human and it's whether or not that's nurtured and if,
whether it's nurtured because you're ignored and you develop on your own or
there it's nurture because you're loved and you're given the freedom to take
chances.
I think either or.
It's like pursuit is what,
it's what's fascinating,
whether it's your life's pursuit or mine or anyone else's where they find an
interest and they study it or they,
they,
they chase it,
they have an idea and they follow it.
You know,
I think that what's most important in your story was that fucking cool guy.
And that you can do that too.
And that we can all,
we can all have these acts of kindness that sort of decades later you're still
describing.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
I,
I completely agree with what you're saying.
And in my life I think it's important to have a sense of gratitude because it
keeps my feet on the ground and to keep reminding myself like,
you've been pretty fucking lucky and you didn't do anything to deserve it.
You just were,
you know,
and so when bad shit comes,
don't forget about that.
Don't start feeling bad for yourself cause oh,
not something bad happened.
Well,
you know,
fuck you.
You,
you,
you know,
you're bad.
Account is very,
uh,
yeah.
It's very weak.
Yeah.
Deal with it.
I mean just stop whining,
living where you live,
live
being Canadian,
you know,
just living in America,
living,
you know,
living in a,
a first world country,
living in a country that has fresh water,
you know,
living in a place where you know,
you don't have to worry about these uh,
armed gangs going through your town and shooting everybody for no reason and no
one even covering it in the news because there is no fucking news that's a big
part of the world,
you know,
always said that the apocalypse is here.
It's just,
it just moves real slow and it's not everywhere.
It hit spots and if you were in Liberia right now,
you would think it's the apocalypse.
He would think you're living in Mad Max Times,
dirt roads and ramping crimes and $1 prostitutes and it's just chaos,
murder and cannibalism.
You would think that you are in the apocalypse because for them than it is.
Yeah.
I your your ideas compelling that you know,
there's too many people and I really wonder how that's going to be worked out
because that's the one I feel like we can work out a lot of social things
because I feel like young people have access to information in a way that really
was never possible for any generation prior.
So I think if there's ever a time where the momentum is going to be at least
slowed,
altered or stopped,
now's that time.
I got to say I,
you know,
I felt really hopeless about Western society until the last four or five years.
And there's a glimmer of feeling like people really want change,
you know?
And,
and I think before now wanting change that badly depended upon things going so
far into the shit hole that,
you know,
it's like revolutionary civil war kind of craziness,
right?
And now things are like tolerable materially.
But I think there is what you were saying,
there's,
there's something happening in the consciousness of young people.
I mean you look at what's happened with acceptance of same sex marriage for
example.
It's like a steamroller.
And 10 years ago,
it was nothing.
It was,
you know,
it was,
it's like things are catching flame really quickly now.
Yeah.
You're ridiculed.
If you have an issue with same sex marriage now.
Exactly.
There's no argument for it.
And that's happened in 10 years.
You know,
I look at Dan savage,
you know,
Dan savage,
the sex,
he's a friend of mine.
And,
and because he basically is responsible for the success of our book.
Right.
I mean,
that's what did everything launched it?
What,
do you have a book?
Oh,
he's got lots of books.
Yeah,
he's got
his famous one.
I could get confused.
Well,
I mean,
he's a,
he's a sexy device.
Columnists.
You're not in there.
There's the Michael,
I guess that was a right wing.
Crazy enough.
Yeah.
This is Dan savage,
who's Dan's.
Have you probably heard about,
um,
what he did to Rick Santorum?
What,
you know,
you don't know about this.
Alright.
So Rick Santorum said,
so this is like seven years ago or something,
and terms says something about how,
uh,
you know,
if if we allow homosexual marriage,
and next thing you know,
men will be marrying dogs and you know,
trees and little shit.
So Dan savage,
who has a nationally syndicated sex advice column called savage love,
it's the most red sex column in the country.
It's in the village voice in the La weekly and it's like in the bay,
you know,
every alternative,
and online the onion,
he started with the onion.
Um,
he's,
he says,
okay,
we've got to like find a definition for Santorum.
What,
what is Santorum?
So he asked his readers to send in crazy definitions for Santorum and then he
had a few people could vote.
And the one that one was Santorum that sometimes that frothy mix of Lube and
fecal matter that sometimes results from anal sex and he sets up a webpage and
then has his readers bomb the webpage.
So if you Google it right now,
Google Santorum,
that's what you're going to get.
So this guy,
his political career was done,
done.
It was like the most brilliant,
you know,
information terrorism ever.
Well Santorum's career was done more because he was found to be a lie.
He's,
he's,
yeah,
he's not,
he's an anti gay guy.
And um,
he also lied about his marathon running time.
Oh No,
no,
that was,
yeah,
it was Rick Santorum.
I,
no,
not Paul Ryan.
Paul Ryan.
Yeah.
Santorum was just crazy.
Anti gay marriage guy.
But I don't think Auntie Don,
if he,
if you know,
there's just this,
there's this,
there's a faction of retards that are still alive in this country that,
you know,
will cling to these like simplest of values.
You know,
they think some of the [inaudible] a man.
Ooh Man.
I was like,
like marriage.
Marriage is ridiculous theory.
It even for men and women,
it's all stupid.
You know,
why not let gay people do that stupid shit too.
That's what he says.
Yeah.
Well,
why the hell did I,
did I raise him those in referenced savage savage was Dan Savage due dates.
Winnie Cooper,
he's married to a guy named Terry and they have a kid.
Oh,
they'll,
why?
He was responsible for the,
the book success,
that he just really pushed it.
And he,
he,
uh,
he read it and loved it.
And then he,
like in his column,
read by millions of people,
he,
he basically said,
buy this book,
you know?
Yeah.
Well you were talking about,
um,
the acceptance of gay marriage.
Oh,
that's the point.
Right.
So my point is that 10 years ago Dan was a radical,
he was way out in the fringes.
Right.
You know,
he was writing this gay sex advice column,
the cracked everybody up.
Um,
but now he's mainstream.
Like he's on the cold bear rapport five times or something.
You know,
he's,
he had a profile in the New York Times.
Dan hasn't changed at all.
He hasn't changed the language.
He uses the things he talks about the political positions he takes.
The stream has changed.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
I attribute that to the same thing.
The information that people have access to now,
they can't just be as flavored by the ignorance of their local area as a the use
to be in the 50 60 seventies eighties nineties whatever when to thousands came
along and people just had a completely new perspective and we have to really
take into account that that's a decade.
Yeah.
I mean we're dealing with two decades of Internet influence.
Maybe a little bit more but not really.
That's pretty much it.
You go to like 92 93 that's about the first evidence of the internet interaction
with our culture.
You've got mail and it goes from that to what we've got now and we're seeing
like real changes look cal Colorado and Washington state and making marijuana
legal and what the fuck is going to happen from there and I think the,
the federal government eventually is going to crumble under the crippling weight
of the ridiculous way they run the system.
Unbelievable.
It's so fucked up that people,
even people that are doing it a certain point in time,
I'm going to be like,
we were being ridiculous.
Like the information is all out there now.
You can't keep running it like this and pretending that we're a democracy and
pretending where representative government all about freedom,
but this is fucking crazy corporate chaos and it's got,
it's got to settle down and then,
and by the way,
everyone's not happy.
Like you're making billions and you're still fucking miserable as shit,
right?
This,
this method of control and financial,
the acquisition of financial wealth,
it's not satisfying for anybody,
you know,
and it,
it's certainly not the best way to,
to have a harmonious nation,
you know?
And I think that's possible.
I think if it's possible to have a great town and it's possible to have a great
neighborhood,
if it's possible,
had a great block and a,
a great group of people that you hang with,
then it's possible to expand that out further and further.
If,
if everyone had a great community and all those great communities combined and
all treated each other as equals and as,
as,
as fellow citizens and this,
this experiment called life.
If everyone had that same exact,
if that same idea,
then a great neighborhood could be the whole world.
I mean it's,
it doesn't seem outside the realm of possibility.
If it exists in the micro,
why can't it exist to the macro?
Well,
it's,
it seems like it should be able to,
and the only thing that seems to hold it back is communication and information.
So there's the language issue,
there's the cultural issue,
but there's the access to each other that's changing and it's changing.
It's such a crazy pace that I'm,
I'm much more hopeful than a I've ever been.
When I was younger,
when I was younger,
I looked at him like,
this is a fucking nuclear war waiting to happen.
This is craziness.
It's all gonna fall apart.
But now I think that people understand the world in a way that's unprecedented.
Yeah.
And I think you're right,
it's,
it's probably entirely due to the Internet.
Like right now I'm,
I'm working with some people to set up a website for the exploration of ethical
non-monogamy.
Right?
So it's,
it's like it'll have a dating site component to it,
but it's also just about a community for me,
a community,
and we were trying to do is have it be it an online community that will also
have regional meetings where you can meet people face to face,
but that it will be set up along the principles of,
of Bonobo.
True.
So females will be respected and you know,
valued.
And there won't be any like hassling of women,
especially women who are openly nonmonogamous,
which attracts some attention.
Um,
but also like,
yeah,
a lot of,
uh,
portion of the profits,
if there ever any profits would go to Bonobo,
uh,
sanctuaries and Congo.
And
so you run like a dating site based on Bonobo monkeys where people get to act
like monkeys,
apes,
sorry.
Yeah.
Among chips.
Hales
monkeys.
A better word.
Yeah,
sure.
You know?
Okay.
The only thing that they don't do is the mother doesn't fuck up
the sun.
That's it.
But that's probably the most important relationship.
It's fascinating though that the mother doesn't fuck the sun because that exists
in humans.
So we talk about Benobos being freaks.
The one thing that they don't do,
that shit's happening all over the south right now.
Mom's fucking their kids for sure too.
We gotta get Outta here.
We're running at it.
Three hours in,
we turn into a pumpkin and I say,
man,
that was a really fun conversation and your book is amazing.
I'm really enjoying it.
It's called sex at dawn.
The author is Dr for Krista Ryan.
Say again.
Dr. Christopher Ryan.
And you can,
um,
you can get this on Amazon,
on kindle.
I have it on a nook.
You can a,
you can buy the actual physical book if you one of those fucking holdouts to a
dark day when needed paper.
Do you read books or do you use a,
like a kindle?
Both.
Yeah.
Kendall's are the shit man.
Those,
those.
Um,
and if you get whispered,
do you have a,
you have the version of it on whisper sync on Amazon where it's read by someone,
don't you?
It doesn't exist.
What do you mean?
Do you know what whisper sync is?
Whisper sync is a,
um,
uh,
an Amazon has of the kindle fire and that he have audible has a application for
it where you read it as a book and then when you get into your car,
it's syncs up to your smartphone.
And a,
uh,
actor reads it as an audio book companion picks up right where you left off.
It's brilliant.
But anyway,
the book is sex at dawn and it's,
uh,
Chris Ryan Phd on Twitter.
And please follow him.
Please buy the book.
It's fucking great.
Enjoy the shit out of it.
And if your wife hides it from,
you know,
your pussy whipped son,
okay.
You know,
you've got to put your foot down.
You gotta be a man.
You gotta get your shit together.
You got to reclaim your,
your heritage.
Thank you very much brother.
It was really,
really fun.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for supporting the podcast leads gentlemen and tuning in.
And thanks for all the positive tweets and messages and Facebook pages and high
fives out there in the,
in the great wide world of reality.
And,
um,
please,
uh,
follow us on Twitter.
Uh,
red ban,
red ban.
And you go to death squad.
Dot TV.
If you want to pick up one of those super sweet desk squad tee shirts with a
psychedelic kitty cat strapped up with bombs.
I don't understand what it means either,
but they're just cool.
Go get them.
Um,
uh,
and uh,
thanks to onnit.com go to o and it used the code name Rogan and saved yourself
10% off any and all supplements and go by blades,
slinger from kerosene games,
and you can get it on the
iPad for $2 99 cents.
All you dirty Fox will be back tomorrow with Brian Callan and,
um,
and maybe an icehouse chronicles as well.
See Ya.
Freaks.
Shit.